Film Courage: “The only person you should try
to beat is the person you were yesterday?”
Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter,
Author, Director, Producer: Yes. I
believe that wholeheartedly
I think that there's this
I don't know I don't know where it comes from but
there's a sense of competition in in the arts and
everybody is looking at their peers the
person next to them and they're trying to
make sure they're one-upping that person
and trying to be better than that person
and then they start following these weird trends
and you find everybody doing the same thing and
their only sense of growth is that their sense
of gross growth is measured by how far they've
distanced themselves from the next person and for
me that's just that's not the case it's a it makes
it very tough to grow and I'm always trying to
learn and grow in everything I do and the only way
you can really measure that growth is if you look
at the work that you've done before and how much
more you've improved how much closer are you to
achieving whatever it is you see in your head
because when I sit down and I write I've seen
the movie in my head and when I step on the set
I'm ready to bring whatever's in my head to the
screen and how the way I gauge my own success
and the way I gauge my own growth is by how much
closer have I gotten to that with each project
I feel like in the beginning I was at maybe I
think one of the first films I did I said I was
probably got like five percent of what was in my
head on the screen because it's all about learning
how to communicate and work effectively with
everyone on the set it's about the team where the
teamwork makes a dream work right and it's about
learning how to work with your team how do you
deliver the information that they need in a way
that they can understand and execute effectively
and with each project I think you're supposed
to grow and get better at that communication
and you can view the work to see your growth
but if you're constantly measuring yourself
by what everybody else is
doing where is your real growth
true let me just play the devil's advocate
for a second though because sometimes
you can have a strong mindset like that but then
you get individuals from the side and they want
to rope you into their competition and it's up
to you to say oh I don't think I'm playing today
but but we're human and we get look the movie
eighth grade for those of us who remember being
a female in eighth grade it reminds
me a lot of that and there's still
an aspect of that to adult life
and especially in entertainment
and so how do you handle when you can tell you're
being challenged and roped into some kind of weird
competitive thing and you're saying no this
is my path my lane is here your lane is there
and I think fortunately I haven't been
wrote in that I do know a filmmaker who
I think they're in competition with me but I think
that that's all in their head because in order
for it to be a competition two people have to be
playing but I don't bother to participate because
I know what it is that I'm trying to accomplish
I know what my lane is and and the the kind of
projects that I'm looking to create and how I'm
looking to create them and realistically the only
person in that lane is is me and even if there
was another person who was doing this the same
or something similar I would give them whatever
knowledge I have to help them succeed at whatever
they're trying to accomplish because that's the
way we all win is if we're all helping each other
I think that if you look at let's just say the
the top one percent in Hollywood right they all
really know each other in some form of
fashion this guy knew that guy who worked
with this guy and they came up and then this
guy reached back and helped this guy and then
this lady helped this guy and this guy helped
this lady that's how it all went everybody helped
everybody get to where they are by not considering
themselves competition by only wanting to see
their peers succeed I think that's the
way it works so even if I did realize
that someone was trying to to rope me into
this this competition I would just say what
do you need from me to help you that that's the
conversation I i'd rather have how can I help you
how can I help you I want to help you grow and
help you succeed I want to help you be the best
you possible so let's start working on that let's
have that conversation you would he would really
do that if you even if you saw like their sort of
underhanded tactics you would really want to help
well I because I guess their underhanded tactics
what would they be for me I don't know what they
would be for me because I don't report to anyone
I finance my own projects so who how can they be
underhanded what I guess if they were trying to
maybe influence an actor to not take the role
or something like that and I would just tell them
ah that's not cool that you did that but I guess
it serves some sort of purpose for you you get
some kind of satisfaction out of it but whatever
because ultimately it's not going to change the
fact that I'm still going to create this project
it's not going to really change that fact
and did you notice that more when you came
here to southern California or
or it was the same in Georgia
people are people everywhere yeah I think people
are people everywhere I think that here it's it's
there's a bit more fuel pushed into the
fire because the stakes are so high and the
opportunities are so small I think that that puts
a little bit more fuel in the fire but in saying
that the people who I found that I worked with
repeatedly are people who they only want to see
everyone around them succeed they're constantly
trying to find opportunities to to bring in
more people that would find some sort of benefit
from whatever they're doing and that's what's made
me keep working with them and I see them being
successful as well I see them being successful
now and it's all because they'd much rather focus
on reaching back and being of use than trying to
compete just be of use like I told you that was
one of the things I learned from john singleton be
abuse be helpful never ruin a good day by thinking
about a bad yesterday yeah that's a good one yeah
leave leave that stuff in the past whatever it
is leave it in the past it's not it's not helpful
it's not helpful I found a lot of people who
sit back and still talk about that film they
made that one time that many years ago and this
person ticked them off and it was this person's
fault and it was that and it was this and it was
leave that stuff alone leave it in the past learn
your lessons and take those lessons moving forward
and apply them to whatever you're trying to create
today if you keep focusing on what happened
yesterday you have no appreciation for what's
happening to you right now in the present and
you definitely can't really plan for the future
because you're too busy thinking about what
happened yesterday yesterday is gone it's gone
so just just leave the problems of yesterday back
there and take the lessons you learned with you
like that one story of the guy that drives
around with no rear view mirror and they
say how come you don't have a rear view mirror
and he says I don't need to see where I've been
that's a great one that's a great one
I'm not sure if it's a real story but
I've heard other people say it so
yeah do you think we can really live
without pain and regret do I think it's
possible to live without pain and regret
i definitely think so I definitely
think so I think that the pain is
just your way of well in in some instances I
can't speak to all kinds of pain because some
pain comes from the grief of of losing someone
or so so I can't speak to that type of pain but
I can take to talk to the pain of any regret of
making poor decisions and I think that ultimately
that kind that type of pain that type of regret
is you understanding you've done something
you've done something wrong whether it be
just incorrect or something actually wrong
and you need to actually fix that and learn your
lesson from that move forward and take that lesson
with you if you are constantly growing from the
things that are happening to you in life if you're
constantly taking those lessons and moving
forward to make sure they don't happen again
I do think you can live without that pain and that
regret that type of pain and that type of regret
yeah certainly justin can you explain to
us why having a plan b I believe used to be
very important to you and then it changed oh yeah
that's easy if you have a plan b you'll most often
use a plan b you'll never go as hard after plan
a if you think you have something to fall back on
throughout my entire life
everything I've done has been
somewhat involved in the arts I told you before I
drew comics wrote stories short stories I was in
the band I did I was in in the in the chorus as
well I'm not a good singer though I was but the
thing about it is it's always been in the arts and
the arts have always been something I pursued but
I've always been told always have a plan b always
have a plan b always have a plan b so even going
to college I had a plan b I knew that I wanted
to be in the arts I knew that I wanted to write
but I all I fell back on on on rotc because
i'd always been in rocc even in high school so
I fell back on that and I had something
to work with if nothing else worked I
could take up something in the military but
ultimately as I moved further and further
throughout this career and I grew more and more
inside of the career in this industry I started
to realize I never went as hard after my plan a
because I was always focusing on keeping my plan b
healthy and all that energy that I was putting
into plan b and constantly thinking of if if this
doesn't work I can escape here and if this doesn't
work I can escape here because I spent so much
time doing that I was taking away a lot of energy
from plan a where if I had invested all of that
and went full bore into that you I would have
been much more successful quicker I think that
I do believe opportunity means preparation and
maybe it was the opportunities were coming along
much later but I think I would have created
all new opportunities had I focused really hard
or and just more on plan a I think that warren
buffett said you only have to be right 51 of
the time that's it you only have to be right 51 of
the time to be successful and if you were throwing
everything you had at plan a the chances of your
success improve greatly did you steal I don't
know too much about rotc but how much of that
training or being around like minds helped you
sort of be resilient and maybe take things less
personal than others might take well I think that
more than anything it teaches you accountability
and responsibility and when you hold yourself
accountable for something it doesn't really matter
other people's critique of whatever you do is it's
either constructive or not and if it's not you
just toss it away because you yourself are holding
yourself accountable to a higher standard than
than most other people would hold you to anyway
so I that's more than anything else is what I
took away from rotc just that accountability and
and the responsibility sure so showing up not only
showing up but but showing up and being prepared
more prepared than everybody else is know
know as much as you possibly can about
everything that's going on and try to make try
to apply that to whatever your specific task is
what kind of heart does it take to pursue this
business or is heart not part of the picture um
heart meaning passion it has to be something that
it has its own rechargeable battery I don't think
I think you have to go hard I think you
have to go hard all the time and you have to
I know for me I was having this conversation while
I was saying before I hear a lot of people say oh
I die to make a movie I die to make a movie
and I say I would never die to make a movie
it's not there's tons of stories you can tell and
all that stuff but I got to finish one because
with all the planning and everything that
goes into making a movie it's having that
passion that's going to help you finish a movie
because for all the movies that are out there
that you can think of think about it this way
if you saw a hundred movies there were probably
50 000 that got they started making but never
finished and of that 50 000 there were probably
a hundred and fifty thousand scripts that were in
development and about to start production so if
you look at that number and it filters all the way
down to just 100 films it's not about getting the
opportunity to make a film it's about finishing a
film and that takes a passion where you where you
have to go into it with the understanding that no
matter how excited someone is about your project
be it the actor the the cinematographer the
editors anybody who's working on that film that's
not you those people for as excited as they are
they do not care as much as you do they never will
so when things start breaking down and it's got
to be spit bubble gum and duct tape to keep it
together and to keep it moving it's going to be
you it's going to be you and the second you get
tired and you can't finish it that's when it
stops that's when it stops because you you're
the you're the person you're the battery you have
to keep recharging that battery that passion you
have to keep it going and it has it has to push
you all the way through every adversity and every
every obstacle to get to completion that has to
push you and it can't die ever because that's
when the project will just cease to exist and once
it's once it stops it's very rare the projects get
picked back up and they finish them it's very
rare so I would I would say in terms of heart
i'd relate it to passion and say that
yeah it has to be a rechargeable battery
that just doesn't die it can't die now if
you're saying what kind of heart in terms of
caring and compassion and that sort of thing
i don't know how far that gets you I don't know
I think if you if you get into films that are
very much about society and how to push society
forward and make people think about the world
they live in and that sort of thing if that's
the direction you're going in I think that
having a heart is for compassion and and love
and and all that great stuff think that it's
I think that it's paramount in that because there
it takes a great amount of will that willingness
to understand people and open yourself up to
to learn about others and to learn about their
cultures and whatever it is that you're going
to be talking about in that film it does take a
great amount of of heart and compassion to do that
to be willing to to completely immerse yourself
in someone else's world but those are two very
different hearts I think two very different hearts
sure and there can be a downside to the other
heart and that things can affect you too much
there's been documentarians that have ended their
lives because they saw things they didn't want to
see yeah about different countries or wherever
and the atrocities that we're going on so that
can it can also take you down because there are
things you cannot see and and once you're made
aware of them your deep feeling for those things
it can affect you in some profound ways in ways
that you you don't expect I will never forget
there was a time back in what was it maybe maybe
oh nine was it on nine maybe all nine oh nine I
was doing marketing for a skilled nursing facility
and it required that I have a nursing background
but I said there's nothing I can't learn so
of course I had to really hit the books and learn
a lot of nursing terms and things of that nature
but I digress the thing was is there was a patient
of the skill nursing facility that ended up in the
hospital and I had to go visit them and just
kind of see how everything was going make sure
social workers were on it and everything
and they told me the guy wasn't going to be
released because now he's definitely in need of
a stay because he has a stage for decubitus ulcer
and I was like stage four to keep it holster I've
heard of those those are bad and they're like
yeah they're bad here's a picture of it and
that picture I cannot see I can't unsee it's a
it's when a bed sore has basically
eaten its way to the bone almost
wow and when I saw that I was like ah why would
you why would you not like give me a second before
you did that that's permanently in my mind and now
I associate it with this patient that I've grown
to care for so now I'm i'm more like emotionally
invested in this person and makes it hard to do
my job now because you're the only thing you're
thinking about is there to keep this ulcer but
you forget the other reasons why they were there
in the first place the only thing you want to do
is make sure that gets healed because that is the
most painful thing that someone can go through
it's an incredibly painful thing and if you if
you've ever seen it of stage 4 decubitus ulcer I
apologize to you in advance that you had to see it
because it's a very nasty wound very nasty wound
did well maybe this is too personal we can cut
this out so i'll ask it and if you don't want to
did you move on from the job I did I did I
eventually I eventually had to move on from
from working in a skilled nursing facility it was
it was a place where you you get to know everyone
by name and you get to to learn their dietary
needs and everything so much about more about
them than their families do and you spend
more time with them than their families do
and you begin to care about them deeply and to
to always after it happens the first few times
when someone that and that you speak to every
day passes away it's like it's a huge shock and
it's something about that realization
when there is no longer a shock
and that was the moment I realized I've been here
too long when I changed from talking about people
that I know and that I care about when I stop it
saying that they've passed away that they've died
I stopped saying that and I started started using
the medical terminology which was they expired
that's when I knew think I
need to step away from this
it had become death had
become way too clinical for me
wow yeah did you take time for yourself after that
or you had to go into another job right away I no
I took a little time away I took a little time
away as a matter of fact think that that was the
impetus to make me say I really just want to focus
on the arts really I started having conversations
with people and don't know how it sounds now I
really don't know because back then it was so
clinical and it still feels clinical when I say
it but I started telling people I've seen the end
live your life the way you want to go out
because ultimately that's what's that's what
we're all doing we just don't know it but we're
living our lives the way we want to go out so
either your mind's going to go first or your body
but live your life the way you want to go out and
as I said that more I realize what
will I will start feeling that regret
that I'm not supposed to feel if I don't
now start going 100 after my plan a
that's when you'll start having that regret when
you see an opportunity that you let pass by and
doing that actually led me into the film ax men at
cutters creek it really did it was because I left
that and I just sat down and really just got back
to writing and said I just want to pursue this and
I want to shoot a film by this date I want to
forget everything I've been doing before this
and I want to shoot this film and so that's what
I did I just devoted all my energy to that and
funny enough a doctor that I met actually ended
up financing that film and so it just worked out
in that way but the impetus for that the the thing
that pushed me to get away from that and into this
was that realization and sorry this was the first
accident the first accident okay so 2012 2013 yeah
we shot it in 2012 I believe yeah 2012 is when we
actually shot it but before that it was it was me
writing and going to everyone and trying to
figure out who was going to finance this thing and
it eventually worked out it was the first
time i'd done that before that prior to
that everything i'd done was self-financed
and then I just realized this one's too
big of a film for me to finance on my own and so I
did go around looking for a financier or producing
partner somebody to help me get the movie made
and so you were we were coming out of a recession
and so with money was tight for a lot of these
investors or yeah money was very tight and two
there's a certain amount of vanity and ego
that comes along with I guess sometimes
financiers so that made it that made
it a little tough it made it a little
tough it was very funny I learned a very an
interesting lesson I have a buddy of mine
and and I don't mind mentioning his name he
won't mind either his name is eddie l watkins
and he's a very big stunt coordinator in the
business and he's producing now as well and he was
in these meetings with me as we were going around
and everything and one of the one of the investors
said what would just prefer if we do these scenes
the way I've written and he hands me pages that
he's now written to rewrite my script right and so
he hands me these pages and he hands one to eddie
and we're in this meeting and eddie
doesn't even read it he just looks at me
and I'm reading him looking at eddie and I'm like
I don't understand why you would do this this is
not I'm trying to give him my notes on what he's
written and the guy is puffing up his chest he's
doing those things and again eddie's just watching
and the guy won't accept any notes he says to us
look this is how the film needs to be written if
you want my money because he who makes the gold
he who has the gold makes the
rules guy actually said that
wow and eddie without missing a beat
says that's only if we want your gold
and I look at him
and he says yeah we're walking that's it meeting
over and we literally walked out of the door and
that was it I thought we finally had a guy and and
he was you don't want to work with a guy like that
because if you don't if you can't get along
with him now and if he has no flexibility now
he'll have none during production and he'll
think that every idea is supposed to end up on
the screen and that's not someone you want to work
with especially if their ideas don't work for the
project and it was very funny because walking
away from that we eventually walked into the
investor that we did use yeah it was a very scary
time because I walked away from that job and I
spent a lot of time trying to get the ball rolling
but what I did was I took plan b and I tossed it
and everything that came below that no plan c d no
escape routes no nothing I want to make this movie
and I want to make it next and that's exactly
what happened because I didn't give myself an
alternative I didn't give myself a way
out of it a way for it not to occur
when you met with the he who has
the gold makes the rules person
how many investors in was that how many meetings
in was that a first meeting no that was probably
our second okay that's probably our second or
third yeah probably our second or third but you
you and and your your friend the stunt coordinator
both just had like a gut reaction like if it's bad
now this is the honeymoon phase it's not going to
be it's not going to improve well here's here's
the back story to that which is that eddie has
been in the industry forever he started out as
eddie murphy's bodyguard that's how he started
out and eventually he got into the industry as a
as a a stunt guy and he eventually got into the
place where he now coordinates all the stunts
and he has just a long history in the film and he
has a lot of experience so he gave me many life
lessons along the way but in this one he he'd done
it so much where he didn't even need to read the
paper it didn't matter because this is the guy
who wrote it and he knows if it's good or not
that was his only point I would know if
it's good or not and if it's not appropriate
for the film we're not going to do it
so that's that's how that decision got made
we republished this tweet from the numbers
game on our channel page and it says squid
game creator wrote the show in 2009 but was
rejected by studios for 10 years he once had
to stop writing the script and sell his 675
laptop due to money troubles and today squid
game is number one I guess in 90 countries and
is set to become the most watched show in netflix
history what is your reaction to this the story
this chain of events if it's true it's awesome
it's that feeling of of the never say die
attitude no matter how much rejection you get
you still keep plowing forward and I love those
stories I do I think that I always if the story
is is completely third party then feel that it's
an awesome story of perseverance but if it's
a netflix story which I'm a netflix subscriber
definitely watch it but they can tell you what's
number one and you just have to believe that it's
true we have no way of verifying that it's number
one only that they said it was number one that I
always wondered that whenever I'm looking at the
the like this is number one for the week and
number 10 for the week I'm like how do we really
know that that's number one in number 10 it's just
because we went there and they told us that it was
so but like I said before if it's the story if
the story is true and it's a third-party story
that's a great story of perseverance think
that we people are born with a lot of quit
in them for some reason or maybe it's developed
over the years but when they start to reach those
obstacles or any kind of adversity it's very easy
to to give up and unfortunately I think that we
all have people in our lives who care about us
greatly they care about us deeply and they will
see us going through some adversity and it's like
oh man it's been years you probably should maybe
maybe you should start thinking about something
else because they care about you and they want
you to be successful and they don't want to see
you kind of beating your head against the wall
and they'll sometimes advise you to maybe maybe
throw in a towel on this one and I'm pretty sure
he had that person next to him telling him that
and when I always hear about people who have those
advisors with them I always say find new advisors
because the only thing that people should help you
understand is why you care so deeply about what
you're doing that's always the real question why
do you care so deeply and after that they should
just be trying to help you achieve whatever the
goal is you're trying to achieve or give you
the best advice they could on how to achieve it
I know you said you left your job as a marketing
coordinator at a nursing skilled nursing facility
but have you ever been tempted to give up on films
as many rollercoaster rides as you've been on it
sounds like no no I I've had times where it was
tough and ultimately you had to feed the safe
you have to say okay I gotta focus on
putting money over here and this and that but
i've I they always say that the the line
between self-belief and delusion is very thin
and I must be riding that line because I I've just
I've always believed especially after I left the
skilled nursing facility that is this or bust is
this robust and I'm very very fortunate that I've
gotten to a point where now I self-finance all of
my projects and think that I can I can service two
different demographics I can service the horror
crowd which is what most people know my work
from is horror and in that like 80s style horror
and then I can also serve a niche of people who
are like me who like the kind of stuff that I
like and that's a smaller niche but I can still
serve that niche and that's where I get to really
be the most creative that I could possibly be but
that took time to get to that point and it took a
lot of sacrifice to get to that point and I think
there are moments in everybody's
life where they realize that
man this is very difficult and I wonder if
the juice is worth the squeeze at this point
but it is my belief that once you start to
feel that that's when you should be your most
decisive in going forward
and the reason is because
success and everything you're looking
for is just on the other side of that
it's when you don't have the teeth to keep going
and you give up you you cut yourself short and
you always wonder what if I had just kept going
what if I had just given it another this or made
that one extra phone call but I never want those
questions and what I found is right when you have
when you get past that point everything I was
looking for was just on the other side it was
just on the other side and I'm starting to reap
a lot of the benefits of that perseverance and
continuously going forward would you say that's
one of your biggest fears is the fear of regret
you don't ever want to get to a certain point and
go I wish I had just done this tried harder um
no think more than anything I just I don't want
to feel like and it's going to sound really
weird but I don't want to feel like life beat me
I don't want life to beat me I've seen life beat
so many people most people around me life
beat them when you ask them what happened
what did most people say life happened man
I had it there and this happened in that
I don't want life to beat me I take everything
that comes with life and I try to use it to my
benefit everything at this point my wife is is is
pregnant right guess who's going to be in my movie
my kid he's going to be the star of the movie you
take everything that's coming to you and you use
it whatever happens in my life I use it if it's
if it's something crazy and wild happen it's a
story in the script if this happened it's in the
script I'm taking everything that comes it comes
towards me and I'm using it I'm using it as fuel
I'm using it as something to keep moving forward
life won't beat me it won't we're hoping to
get your reaction to this comment and that is
this is not a triumph it's a tragedy and it's a
sign of just how much the industry needs to do
better because creative original work should
not be just a long struggle to put it out
referring to the squid game and
what are your thoughts on that
um
he didn't let life beat him no he didn't let
life beat him but to say it's not a triumph it's
a tragedy it's like wow really I don't I look you
everything that we do especially in this industry
everything you're trying to do is met with
resistance and opposition it just is it is if
the way I try to explain it to certain people when
they say oh it's nepotism and this person and that
and this is why I can't get in and okay let's say
you are trying to to get through the door okay
in every film I've worked with let's say
we take the collective of everybody I've
worked with in that film maybe seven percent
of them are people I actually work with again
maybe okay and it all has to do with the way I run
my set and what I expect from people in the end
not everybody is gonna operate at that same level
okay and while I can be very chill I can also be
pretty intense now because I'm very passionate
about what I'm doing so if that's the case
after a certain amount of time I'm hopeful that
the percentage of people that I'm working with
is growing so that now I'm carrying over
most people from one project to the next
why am I doing that because these are the people
that I know these are the people that I trust
okay and I want to keep them next to me
and I want to keep them working with me
so when the next person comes along and they say
well guess what I can do this and I can do that
I say you probably could and you're probably
great at it but then I would have to take a chance
and maybe on this project I'm already taking
these chances I can't afford to take that chance
and that person can see that as an obstacle to
their growth into their success because they
couldn't get that position on that film they
couldn't get that thing out there and if they
go to more and more people like me who begin
to accumulate a nice team that they work with
a very a team that makes everything work smoothly
they're going to meet that same opposition right
and it will become a game
in terms of trying to find
that crack to squeeze in to get whatever it
is that you're trying to to get made made so
when people speak of the struggle to get things
done that's really the struggle the struggle is
first of all he's written something right and
he has to get it in front of someone to read it
well guess what there's hundreds and thousands
of other scripts that are trying to be read
everybody's trying to get their stuff made the key
is going to be the perseverance and to keep going
and that to me is the triumph of the story as
I said if it's if it's the true story and it's
a third party and they're talking about it to
me that is a triumph that's not a tragedy it's
a triumph you took something that is not a very
it's not a cheap story to make like he can't go
out and get a a camera phone and shoot that like
it doesn't work the same he's gonna need a serious
budget guess what that's even more competitive
because to get people to spend the millions
of dollars it's going to take to make that and
market that that's tough it's very competitive
and it shouldn't be easy because if
it were easy wouldn't be worth it
so excuse me sorry disagree with that it's not a
it's not a tragedy it's a triumph what was behind
door number one what we didn't tell you what was
missing from that tweet is that director huang
did not stop during those 10 years he kept working
and he wrote and directed I guess three projects
during that time and a lot of people they may have
just been stuck on that first one and trying to
make that one happen so he for whatever reason
kept going and made other work and don't know
the exact story of how it happened but it sounds
like he wasn't going to let life beat him down
either so yeah it's a story of perseverance like
I said he he may feel that it was a tragedy he may
because two people looking at the same event
can see two totally different things right
to me that's not a that's not a tragedy to me
that's a triumph and hearing that he made other
projects while he was trying to get that one made
even further solidifies that it's perseverance at
its best and it's never giving up and his plan a I
don't think was just to make squid game his plan a
was to to be successful and get something made and
that's exactly what he was getting done squid game
just took a little bit longer than the others but
ultimately he got that one done as well when you
were on your way out from the nursing home did
people try to talk you out of leaving yes yeah
but I always make sure that I seek first
to understand and then to be understood
and I could understand why they didn't want me
to go because I was a salesman and I was pretty
decent at what I did so
they didn't want me to leave
because then that meant that they would
have to find another salesperson and then
they'd have to take a gamble and see if that
person would work out and when it comes to
the healthcare industry especially when it's end
of life and it's assisted living facilities at
skilled nursing facilities home health and hospice
is super competitive it's super competitive so you
need very aggressive salespeople and that was
ultimately why they didn't want me to go I think
there were a couple people who just like talking
to me every day yeah and those people didn't want
me to go and I think a few of the patients
but I think or residents I should say but
for the most part it was it was because of my
skills that they didn't want me to leave and
once I understood that I said that's even more
of a reason to to to kind of leave and not feel
too bad about it well they try to talk jeff
bezos out of making amazon so well there you go
can you talk about the decision that you
were not going to make movies by committee
anymore and what does that mean it's for me it's
it's about it's going back to accountability
and being able to hold myself accountable for
for not growing for not achieving the level of
growth that I need to achieve when you're making
a movie by committee which I understand completely
that most industry movies are made by when it's
a studio or whatever but going through that many
levels of decision making and this person
believes they know what's better for the
film they know what's better for the audience
they know what's better for marketing they know
I believe you need one voice we need one
voice that ultimately makes the decision
of what to do inside of the film you can
definitely confer with everyone around you
when I hire an actor I hire them because they are
the best at what they do and they fit this role
and when they read the script
they're going to be able to tell me
things to a level of detail that maybe I haven't
thought about right and I trust their intuition
and I'm going to figure out a way where we
can kind of make that work inside the film
but that's not what by committee what by
committee is a executive producer who now
says what and this is a real thing that happened
yeah I think we need a topless scene right now
and how there's in what way it's like at what
time would somebody take their clothes off that
doesn't even make any sense there's a murderer
running around and everybody's in the same room
like what would be the reason that they would
need to it's like a lot of those decisions that
are just made because people want to be heard
and they want to see whatever they've said show
up on the film it's a vanity and ultimately when
you're making movies like that and by committee
with multiple people having all of this input your
film is getting further and further and further
away from what you're trying to achieve and as I
said the only person I'm really competing with is
the person that I was yesterday I'm constantly
trying to grow and how can I measure my growth
if everything around me is being affected
by people who are not me and people who've
already articulated that it has to be in there
or basically they can withdraw funding that's
ultimately what it is is that the decisions when
they're being made by committee are made by people
who can ultimately make the decision of if you
won't do what I'm asking you to do if you won't
put this in the film I can withdraw funding and
I can do it at any time I can do it at any point
because again they're not as invested in the film
as you are they're invested in their own vanity a
lot of times not not all the times there are some
great financers out there and some great executive
producers but unfortunately I haven't worked with
them but the ones that I've worked with have been
kind of vain and and it has been the vanity of
having whatever was in their head added to the
film even if it doesn't make sense story-wise sure
and and in any relationship where someone's giving
you money they they kind of own you in a sense
they do they do and especially when that they
can pull the plug and it's the reason why I have
overlooked a lot of the things that have been done
on on the set you have to let a lot of things
go and try to control the things you can control
but along the way this committee will continuously
try to influence everything that you do
and it makes your personal growth and measure you
can't measure it because it's not really you it's
you plus that guy and that lady and that kid
it's you plus all of this when it should be you
making the sole decision now you can
take inspiration from what other people
say you can take some advice from what other
people say if it applies if it's applicable
but you can ultimately decide if it's not
and I only began to get that sense of freedom
when I started to to finance my own
projects that's when I began to see
it what kind of sacrifices did you have to
make to be able to finance your own work um
security
financial security oh yeah for a while
for a while financial security um
a lot of things that probably so many to to
too many to name but things that would have
certainly made my young lady happy we had to
sacrifice a lot with the sacrifice a lot of
time that you would normally spend together I was
holed up by myself doing so many things myself
because whatever you can't pay for you have to
assume that responsibility yourself so even when
we would be sacrificing financially we were also
sacrificing just the time we got to spend together
and it was it was very hard time in the beginning
a very hard time but here's the thing is
and I don't advise that people just run out and
start self-financing their own stuff would say
before you do that understand how distribution
works because once you understand how you make
your money back then you can justify
how much money you spend on a project
right you don't want to give yourself you
don't want to take a loan out for eighty
thousand dollars hundred thousand dollars and
make a movie that you're only going to make five
thousand dollars from you need to stack as many
of the of the statues stack as much of the deck
in your favor as possible so but in the beginning
I certainly had to sacrifice financial security
and I had to sacrifice a lot of time and spend a
lot of time away from my lady and I've been away
from my family since 2004. I go back home every
once in a while to Georgia but for the most part
my family has seen me on average maybe once every
three years to maybe maybe every two years but
I probably lean towards the three I don't go home
that often so there's been a lot of sacrifice to
get to where I am today and when you're writing
a script is it now in your mind that okay this is
going to cost too much and I'm not going to make
my money back on this I have to change the scene
no I'm always aware of the story that I'm
writing and the budget that it falls within
I make sure I tell the truth in the story and
budget should never dictate truth but budget
should dictate what you're trying to do
as a whole I don't think you should make a sci-fi
opera if you only have two thousand dollars think
that that's a that's setting yourself up for
for failure I think that if you're going to tell
a very intimate story between two characters that
they met outside of a motel in the parking lot
and they're developing this romance over two days
at the motel and one guy is there on a business
trip and the lady lives there yeah whatever but
if you're trying to make something very small
and mostly just the conversations that they have
between one another and those that's easy to do
and that's very inexpensive but if one of them
is a cybernetic organism and they shapeshift and
they walk they walk through these wormholes that
constantly open up and now all the machines are
coming out to attack everybody and the motel blows
up then I think you've kind of set yourself up for
for for failure you used to rely on investors
to make your films now you don't and we'd love
to know the economics of what you did when you had
investors and now what you do as a self-financier
I would say that now I make less financial
mistakes when I worked with investors
knew enough to know that I was always going
to need a reserve right so whenever I spoke
to someone about the budget I always said
make sure we also have this much in reserve
and I wrote the script and most often times more
often than not I would have to use that reserve
and you would often find that you're using that
reserve in post-production because more of the
money got used in production than you thought
would have been as I've now began to do it myself
I budget I budget actually over what I would
actually need and I try to save as I go along
as opposed to the working backwards where
you budget just enough and then I was like oh
this cost more than I thought it would or maybe
we missed a day and then we have to add another
day to production or you you don't realize the
problems you're going to have until you start
having them and that was what I was going through
during the period of time of having investors
so now think I make less financial stakes less
less budgetary mistakes and scheduling mistakes
now that I'm financing it myself and it's
mainly just because I have the experience
and how are you able to save because how
different things can happen there can be
rain and you have to shut it down
for the afternoon different things
what are some of the things you've learned can
help actually save on production we always have
you have the schedule as it's supposed to be
but then we know that if we have days where
weather impacts shooting then we have like
a safe shoot so we always know okay these
are the things we're going to shoot but if on
any one of these days rain is not permitting or
something happens out on the road or whatnot
we can go back and we can shoot this inside
and that way you don't lose any days you're
just moving things around in the schedule
I think that one of the I think about this day
and it's just I'm like how could I be so crazy
we were shooting axe man actually and one of the
days the the executive producer showed up and uh
for whatever reason he came in we were
shooting one scene inside and then
we're supposed to be shooting something else
outside and then it just started pouring rain
and so we came in and we all sat down
and we just waited for the rain to stop
hours we waited for the rain to stop instead of
shooting anything else we were actually shooting
something indoors already and then we stopped
shooting that because that was over and then we
decided to shoot outside when we couldn't shoot
outside we didn't shoot anything and it was a
completely lost day like I want to say four hours
of not shooting when we could have been shooting
any number of scenes and shot inside and that
was one of the biggest takeaways from that is
once I thought about it I was like I am I am nuts
for allowing that to happen we should have moved
on and shot something else so I as again I learned
a lot of things early on that I carried over into
the ones that I executive produce now as well
and so that's all the lessons I've told you
every time something happens you have to learn
that lesson and carry that lesson forward
and that was that was one of the ones that I
certainly learned so I always have backups for
exterior shoots so even if you have to shoot
something out of order then as long as just just
keep keep everybody there and keep it rolling
yeah yeah the only the only film where that
would have been tough was the one I just finished
shooting once and one that one we had the we had
the complexity of the beard because his beard was
either there or not there and so everything with
the beard had to be shot together so you couldn't
jump the line and go shoot something else because
he's not supposed to have a beard so that
was the only one that presented an issue
how much money was going into your movies when
you were dealing with the financiers we we always
made sure we didn't spend more than a hundred
we never spent more than a hundred I really
unless you're shooting with massive names or
if you're shooting something that of course
if it's something that is going to use up
most of the budget like we I just finished
working with someone who was doing a film where
it's dinosaurs and it's a very different thing
right so so a lot of money is going to
go towards cgi and all that stuff so
but if if you're shooting the kind of movies
that I shoot that rely on practical effects and
things of that nature and the stars are not huge
and stuff like that I don't believe it should go
over a hundred I believe anytime you're going
over a hundred you're really rolling the dice
I think you're rolling a dice anyway but you're
really rolling the dice over a hundred because
I believe that with a smart marketing plan even
with a bunch of flaws you can make back a hundred
if you go to 250 you go to 350 and you don't have
huge names attached or if you don't have a whole
lot of marketable elements you could you could dig
a hole that you can't climb out of so it's always
been under 100 and I try to keep most of my movies
under 100. and if you factor in a lot of the
the discounts I receive on things you could really
see my budgets kind of coming in at around 250.
that that's what they would be like if I was
being charged full rate for a lot of things
and so 100 sorry for the entire production
including post and deliverables and and
prints and advertising yes okay and were all those
films profitable that had financiers attached
I would say that in the beginning no they didn't
they became they became more profitable after I
got them back and after I marketed them myself the
reason being is this and that's why I just gave a
one answer a one word answer of no and the reason
is because earlier on I thought if I give my film
to a distributor then that distributor
is going to market my phone they're going
to sell it all over the place and then I'm
just going to break in a bunch of money and
it'll be awesome and that's not really what
happens a distributor basically places your film
and if no traffic gets driven to those places you
don't make any money so ultimately it's your job
your responsibility as a filmmaker to drive
traffic to that film or to to drive traffic
to those places where it can be purchased right
or rented or whatnot so if you're not doing that
you're not making money and if you this back
in the day when sales agents really mattered
that sales agent could take the film and sell
it here and sell it there and sell it there but
nowadays that doesn't really matter unless it's
a huge film or it has a very huge name attached
even though those things don't matter
so you have to understand not only that
it's your responsibility to do so but you have to
also understand how to accomplish it how to drive
traffic to those places so that you make
money so no when those films were released
they were not profitable then
but they are profitable now
so it's not just enough to get a distributor to
put it on itunes or google play or whatever you've
got to have a plan in place to get eyeballs
to go to those links correct correct that
was that was one of the biggest lessons I had to
learn and not only learning that that was my job
but figuring out how to do it because it can be
very tricky it can be very tricky because the the
amount of films that are out that are constantly
coming out is just crazy and if you think about it
as as filmmakers most filmmakers think oh this
person's in the film this and all these people
know other people and everybody's talking about
my film amongst each other oh man I'm doing it
it's huge and it's like no because you're
just talking to other people in the industry
and yeah everybody else in the
industry is talking about it but
they're really not your audience and they're
really not the people who are going to
make your film a success they're not
unfortunately the audience is the people
who you're marketing the film to in terms of
a paying audience who that's their interest
that's that those are the people who you want
to be aware of your film those are the people
who you want talking about your film and as
I began to notice it more and more I even
took my own personal facebook page down I took
it down because it was for what I was doing it
was worthless and it was a waste of time because
everybody who I knew worked in the industry and
we all pumped each other up and oh you're awesome
and that stuff doesn't matter that stuff does
not pay the bills pumping each other's ego up is
that's all it's doing is pumping you pumping each
other's ego up so I got away from that completely
and just started really focusing on how do I find
my audience and how do I keep them engaged
and then how do I best convert that audience
to a paying audience how do I best do that and
those were things I just learned along the way
so maybe your audience let's say would be the
people that would attend a horror convention in
middle america rather than people on either coast
that are also looking to be cast correct okay yeah
but unfortunately and you don't know it really on
on on like when you're on like a me social media
platform like facebook and everybody's friending
you friending you like oh my movie's so popular
and it's only after you sit back and you look at
it that you realize man every single one of these
people are either actors or composers like what is
this like I got seven thousand friends well I've
five thousand friends and four thousand and eight
hundred of them are other actors and and composers
like that's that's the the list of and that's not
my audience that's not who I'm really looking to
to convert those are the people who I'm looking
to keep engaged they're already engaged because
they're looking for work so I had to learn how
do I how do I find my audience and how do I
keep them engaged how do I keep them happy
and I really started to notice when I got
ax man back and I just kind of put out a blurb
about it guess what guys I got it back and then
everybody was like oh that's awesome blah blah
blah and what are you going to do now oh I'm going
to re-edit it oh you're going to re-edit it how is
it going to be different and people were actually
really engaged and we had a lot of back and forth
and I had people writing me I always thought this
should have happened in the movie I'm like we
already shot it it's like it's I'm re-editing
but I'm not going back and reshooting things it's
been a while I think everybody's age at this point
but just looking to go back and re-edit it and
then get it closer to the vision that I had for
it and they were just so excited and engaged and
when the movie came out it was instantly great it
was instant instantly profitable and one of the
coolest things about it was I didn't even release
it for people to rent or purchase I released it
directly to amazon prime and 2btv and that was it
just those two just those two platforms now
it's since expanded but just I would even say
even if you remove amazon from the
equation which if most filmmakers haven't
they should in terms of av or in terms of
svod you should remove that from the from
your overall vision of how much money the movie is
going to make and really focus on places like 2b
because that's where I would say 95 of
the revenues come from has been from 2b
and with 2b are there forced ads yeah okay so
you you have to watch the ads sure you have to
watch tv and I think every movie it starts
with like two or three ads and then it goes
into the movie and then a few minutes in it's
another four or five ads and then they go and so
if you keep people engaged if you have quality
content you keep people engaged each time they
pass one of those commercials you're making more
money and so that's the name of the game is is
avod for for certain movies for certain movies now
if you have a movie like like the my most recent
film one-to-one if you have something like that
where you have a couple of names that are in the
movie that people recognize that's something you
want to really push and see what tvod has to offer
transactional video because the odds are a lot of
people will go there to rent or purchase that film
because they recognize those people and because
the content may be something they're interested in
did you use an aggregator to get it on to be or
amazon prime or these other you said with the v
sorry with the watson want you yeah yeah yeah with
the smaller films I go through filmhub actually
filmhub is a great resource because mainly because
I think for most people the barrier to entry is
too high from going with a traditional aggregator
because they're going to charge you per platform
they're going to first of all have a set fee and
then any platform after that is another fee and
another fee another fee and another fee right
now if you anticipate and when I say anticipate
I don't mean hope but you've actually done the
homework and you anticipate making I don't know
500 grand right unless I'm just going to use that
ballpark figure if you anticipate making 500 grand
from your film and you went through
an aggregator then you paid them up
front so that's all they got so if you paid
them if you paid them up front and it was
2500 bucks then that's all they got
and you got all the rest of that money
but if you went through film hub well film hub
you didn't pay anything up front they take I think
it's I think it's ten percent so if they're taking
ten percent then they took fifty thousand dollars
which is huge but if you anticipate because you've
done the research and films in your certain budget
range they maybe only hit a certain number then
and that you're gambling anyway then filmhub is
better because there's no real barrier to entry
you can just put the film in see how it does and
let's say you you crap out at ten thousand right
game's over it's made up it's made ten thousand
and from now it's petering out then you didn't
spend anything to get into the game and if you if
filmhub takes their percentage they've only taken
a thousand dollars is there a period of time when
the film kind of peaks or depends on the title
in terms of like viewership is it the first month
I think it all depends I think it depends
on your how you've promoted the film
or if you even know anything about promoting
because I didn't in the beginning and I know
my film came out and I know people were watching
it but I had no idea how they were watching it
i never sent them anywhere to watch it it grew
a following but don't know how much of that was
how much of that was from them finding the
actual places where it was being shown and
watching it through there or just watching a
pirated link I would have no way of knowing
because I never I never invested the time in
understanding how to market to an audience
so I didn't have that information at my disposal
but as I as I moved more into understanding the
marketing of a film I can say that I usually will
feed that audience engage that audience and then
point them to where I need them to go and I can
watch the film through every quarter actually
with filmhub because you can piece out the
rights you can take the rights and do this by
yourself and then filmhub only handles this but of
everything I'm seeing I can see it month by month
what's happening and see how much money I'm
generating how many views I'm getting month
over month and I usually find that in
the first quarter that's where you get
the larger number of people viewing your
film because that's when it's still hot
that's when it's most exciting and everybody
wants to watch it and see what happens
and then it starts to kind of find a little medium
and it rise that probably for another two quarters
and when you say peace out the rights what does
that mean meaning you own it in perpetuity but
then they own it for a certain time certain
amount of uses no actually film hub doesn't
they you're not even you're licensing it to them
but it's for no predetermined amount of time
so at any moment you can just stop it you can
say what I'm not liking this anymore I'm just
going to stop it now and you can choose to do
so and what by piecing out is if you're going
to it's different now but in the beginning if
you wanted to keep amazon rights for yourself
because ultimately why would you want somebody to
upload to amazon when you could do that yourself
so for a lot of people they kept the amazon rights
themselves and then they would put the rest of
their the rest of the platforms on on filmhub
and then they would make all their money that way
and so as amazon has moved away from allowing
direct uploads for a prime they've moved away
from that recently so I say recently like it was
just now but I think it was beginning of 2021 they
moved away from that model so yes you can upload
your film and it can be tvod for rent for purchase
but it won't go to amazon prime unless it was
put up by another distributor or an aggregator
really do why they did that the rumor is that it
was because so much of prime was cluttered with
not that quality content because people were
saying oh it's a feature film and really it was
just a bunch of episodes of something they put
on youtube like like like them what was one of
the ones that was like a tutorial on something
like nails and stuff or something they just put
together a bunch of episodes and it equaled out
to like 45 minutes and they just uploaded that
and now that's considered a movie and so I think
amazon just they got enough backlash from that
and they decided it's not worth it for us to allow
people to do that now we need somebody curating
that content I think that was part of it I think
the other part of it too is ultimately amazon
creates their own content and so you're even
though I know I know a lot of people think that
we're not really in competition with with amazon
because they have these huge big shows that are
watched by hundreds of thousands of people if not
millions of people we're not competing with that
and essentially yes you are you just not you
by yourself but if you and you and him and her
and we all got together and there was a thousand
films that hit amazon prime if you add up all the
people watching that content it is rivaling their
shows it's taking attention away from the stuff
that they've created so I think it's those two
reasons in tandem that really pushed him to make
that decision and say what I think let's put an
end to this let's make it a curated thing where
at worst I'm sorry at best they're going to have
to go through through film hub and and I think
so many people still don't know about film hub
and I think if you if you knew about film hub as
a as an independent filmmaker you would never
rely on another predatory distributor again
you never would because you realize they're
completely inconsequential you can give your
film away to this guy over here who will make
money off your film and you'll never see a dime
or you can do it yourself and put it on film hub
and chances of you saying money is far greater
it would keep people out of making some really
bad bad deals with distributors with bad intent
and do they have certain specs that they require
aspect yeah yeah yeah yeah they they do they do
specify the the formats that you must submit
and they do specify how many moments of black
that you can have so that the films are pretty
uniform so you're not having more than I think
more than two seconds of black at the beginning
and not more than two seconds of black at the end
that sort of thing just so that movies
start because I know there are people
who try to pad things out and oh if I throw
on two minutes of black at the beginning and
five minutes of black at the end my movie's now
83 minutes so I think they try to do that but but
ultimately it's just something to keep it uniform
why have you put your films on 2b at the
moment it's probably the greatest revenue
generator because people get to watch it for
free it's a free app that's in pretty much
i would say almost every english-speaking
territory and even some non-english-speaking
territories so it's widely available
just as much so as amazon prime and
it's it runs off ad revenue so it's completely
free unlike amazon prime where you have to have
a membership whatever you pay per year your
annual membership with 2b you just download
the app to your phone or to the computer or
to your television and you're able to watch
films completely for free just everything all the
revenue is generated from from advertisements so
we recently heard that a filmmaker said that
he made like six figures from toby can you tell
us your experience six figures yeah definitely
possible I think it depends upon a lot of factors
I don't know if this filmmaker did it on one
film because that's a different set of factors
versus he just had a bunch of his films on
there and that's a different set of factors
but depending upon the factories yeah
certainly all it really all that really
needs to happen is that you drive an audience
that you've been interacting with to to be
the only the only pushback I would say I received
in terms of of why someone hasn't viewed a film of
mine on 2b was just that they didn't know what to
be was they didn't know how much it was going to
cost so they didn't bother to download it that's
the only thing I think that as more people become
acquainted with 2b I think that's going to be the
place to go to to place a film and I've actually
been in in talks with them so that I don't
have to go through an aggregator in order to
place films there because all they really want to
see is that they're not dealing with a filmmaker
who has one film they want to deal with someone
who has multiple films so that they aren't just
dealing with one offs of having to have different
bank accounts to pay or whatever so that's why
they deal with aggregators that's why they deal
with distributors because they're just paying
one person for a lot of films versus
one-offs so you don't have let's say
a dashboard within 2b that you can go
and see what you made for this quarter
I don't have it because I don't have a direct
relationship with them yet but I'm about to have
a direct relationship with them for right now I
see all of my revenue projections from filmhub
okay right why do you place such an
emphasis on owning your own movies
I believe that that is the only way to operate
with any type of freedom in this industry
to be tethered to a committee to be tethered
to someone who holds the purse strings
it just already this this industry you have to
have a thick skin already and it's an artistic
industry it's not like it's being an accountant
or something it's actually you relying on your
own creativity and your ability to take what's
ever in your head and apply it in reality to
make it come true right you're trying to do all
these things and then ultimately you have so many
people around you that are that could be whether
it's negatively or positively influenced in that
and manipulating it and they don't mean to they
don't mean to it's not like I don't think many
people are out to just screw you over with bad
ideas I think that everybody just wants their
own thing they want their own imprint on whatever
it is and it really hampers your your freedom and
your ability to grow but if you if you were able
to finance your own projects and you were able to
understand the distribution process
so that you understand how much
money you generate from that then you've taken
so much of your own financial freedom and your
creative freedom into your own hands that's why
I really emphasize owning your own rights and
not I don't even license my stuff out unless I
know that this person can do something that I
can't do and even then I'm only licensing the
rights to them for the things that I can't do
on my own that's it because I know that if
I licenses it licensing to them for I don't
know two three years that's two or three years
that I'm tied to them on this specific thing
and if I learn how to do that in that specific
in that during that time I can't even do anything
about it because they're already doing it
so I have to wait until their license is up
before I can do it myself because I like to I
like holding me accountable I like making myself
responsible because that's the only way I know for
sure 100 that it will get done and get done to the
level that I would do it or that I want it to be
done so in all of this what I'm trying to do is
take all of my projects and use them to not
only express myself artistically but also
to provide my own security moving forward how
do filmmakers continue to make movies if their
films aren't profitable they can't not
from any standpoint you can't do it if you
rely on investors and you can't do it if
you're relying on yourself financially
the best thing that I can ever recommend is
but that's why I always say I always give
before I tell someone oh make it yourself I tell
them to learn distribution and learn what your
specific film what on average does that film
kind of make based on a number of different
factors and then you try to stack as many of the
marketable elements into your film as possible
so that while you're being free creatively to
create whatever you want to and to finance that
you've stacked a certain number of things in
your favor to make it profitable if not for you
for the person that invested in the film how
does someone really learn distribution though
without really having gone through sort of
the the heart school of hard knocks with it
that's the that's the catch-22 I think that
everything that you learn about if you if
you watch a video and someone explains
to you this is how everything works and
that's how it worked when they made
that video because it's already changed
things that worked in 2014 don't work today they
just don't because as equipment has become cheaper
and the ability to market the
film has become more democratized
more people have started
making films than ever before
now anything that you've learned leading into
this period of time you've been able to build upon
but if you're now watching things back then about
how the industry works you are so far behind
you're so far behind the best
way that you're going to learn
is to take a certain amount of money that you
can afford to lose and get in the game that's
really the best way that you're gonna learn it if
you've got a thousand dollars you can make a film
and I'm telling you this because I made a film
that's in distribution and it cost me 1500 bucks
and it's on to be right now I think it's on to me
which is adam k right that film cost me 1500 bucks
and I have a name in it fair abraham who she
was number one trending on twitter at that time
but yeah roughly 1500 bucks is what it cost me
to make that film you can do that and you can get
into the game that's the best way that you're
going to learn how to do it because trying to
to gather that information from things online
I think you'll end up being behind the ball
when it comes to distribution specifically when
it comes to how to write a story when it comes to
how to cast actors when it comes to how to produce
a film when it comes to development when it comes
to those things those things are integral to
getting the film going but the conversation
that needs to happen before that is the one
that keeps changing which is distribution
because all that affects everything else until
you get to that point and that's the part that
just keeps changing so the best way to understand
it is just shoot something just shoot something
anything it's so cheap to do so right now it
whether they have the the iphone you can plug the
little anamorphic lens adapter for 100 bucks on
the back of it and then you're shooting something
just go do it understand unders understanding
the windows of how to release things is important
but you only learn all of those things after
you've distributed something after you've already
invested in it or you've gotten someone else to
invest in it so it's like if you're in a flight
simulator or you're let's say playing some day
trading game unless that's like your real money or
you're really flying that plane you're not really
going to learn it's going to be you're going to
take more chances and different things and so when
you really have skin in the game it's different
yeah it's very very different it's very different
and I'm going to tell you it's so funny that when
I was making a film by committee with financiers
and stuff and I would say I I really believe that
we should have this in the film and and this and
it would help give out all these great ideas but
it was coming from a creative standpoint right
and at that time I hadn't really learned about
the marketable elements like why this film
needed to be made and why does it need to
be made this way those were the things I didn't
understand or I should say I applied all of those
questions to the creative part of it and not
the distribution part of it and I had all these
ideas and it was like ah but if if someone
had those ideas today and they were asking
me about making a movie I would tell them to
stop just stop what you're doing right now
I'm going to explain to you why that's
not the conversation you should have
right now right now you should be defining
who is this film for and don't say yourself
don't say yourself unless a lot of
people like you and how to reach them
don't say that figure out who your audience is
for this movie because if who your audience is
you'll know what's important to them and you'll
know if what you're talking about is important at
all especially if you have to spend money because
every idea you come up with all I hear is a cash
register that's all I hear because it's going to
cost money in order to do it so just make sure
that it benefits the film somehow financially and
if you've got enough marketable elements sure be
free go off and do whatever in mid-sentence make
a wormhole open and the guy gets sucked in and
whatever I don't whatever it is you're thinking
about doing just make sure that you've done
the homework up front to define your audience
because that's ultimately what's going to matter
are you able to know the exact moment like
let's say a film is paused and re-watched or
where people drop off with your movies do it to
that much the analytics are that strong for you
yes and no it through amazon you don't know it
through the others and that's only because you're
going through an aggregator that aggregator
has that information but they typically don't
share that information but if it's if it's if it's
amazon prime you can definitely see where people
are falling off and and and you'll sometimes rack
your brain wondering why why why at this moment
and you go back and you look at you can't see it
but there's there are things where people just
they fall off for whatever reason but yeah you
can see it you can see it think in all honestly
that's how I don't I don't know if
this is bad to talk about or not but
with netflix people have started to become a
little bit disenchanted with the content sometimes
right and they always say it just seems like like
there's no real connection and I said well there
may be a reason for that because they can see
the analytics and they can see when something
drops off maybe they think they know why and they
go back and they look and they're like oh I see
because yeah there was before that this brunette
was in it and she walked through and then she left
the scene and then people stopped caring so that's
what we need we need more brunettes we need more
hers or whatever that's what it was it they don't
know but they think they know because they have
they have the analytics and they're looking at
it and trying to dissect it and figure out what
any of it means and they're doing it to such a
granular level that it's got to be maddening but
I think that's what they're doing I think they're
using that same that same stuff to try to figure
out how to make movies that keep people engaged
more because ultimately that's why it exists
is for you to see and for you to know that
people are falling off do you think making
a successful independent film is like winning the
lottery it depends on your definition of success
if your definition of success is you made a
movie for 10 grand and it made 10 million that's
definitely a lottery ticket I don't think that
there's any way that person planned to do that
but my definition of success is how much closer
did I get to the vision that was in my head when
I was making the movie how much closer did I get
did I get closer this time than I did last time
because that's a success for me and one one day
I want to be able to look at a film and say I got
exactly what was in my head because I pleasing
this guy or this lady whatever like that that's
not really what I'm making films for what I'm
making films for is to to get closer and closer
to the movies that are in my head I want to I
want to I want to get all the stuff that's in here
on a page and from a page on the screen and
do it in such a way where I didn't compromise
too much I didn't compromise
too much if if your successes
who you got to be in the movie or who who saw
your movie and reached out to you I think quentin
tarantino was trying to make reservoir dogs as a
short film and his success is that he made it to
I want to say he said he made it to harvey keitel
or somebody and that person was like are you crazy
this should be a feature that's a success you
were going to make something small and then
it became huge that could be a success it all
depends on what your definition of success is
so that vision it sounds like has always been
there because when you went to that one investor
who said here are my notes and it's
my way or we don't make this thing
you knew that no it had I really want what was in
my head to be on that screen this isn't going to
work for me well I would say it wasn't as strong
back then the only thing I knew was that his notes
or his new scenes didn't fit the film it just
didn't fit the film like to give you an example
there's a there's the people go walking off to go
look for this guy and he wrote in a scene where
one of the characters lady pulls up in a in a
jeep and her like oh how'd you go back and get
the jeep and she's like well my father used to
race jeeps back in the day through the desert
and like what does that have to do with anything
it was just it was the most useless piece of piece
of backstory and why would they have a vehicle if
they had a vehicle then they could just leave like
it was just it opened the thing for like
why it doesn't make sense in this film
and that was the reason why I didn't want it in
the film not because it wasn't part of my vision
but because it just didn't fit in the film and
none of the things that he wrote fit in the film
now I would say if if someone comes to me and
they can give me very sound advice I had it on the
previous film where somebody came to me and they
said I just I don't really get this and then we
talked about it and I realized wow from a really
objective sense your idea does work better than my
idea and so we we took that idea and incorporated
it into the film so I'm not so much about um
being so vain as to say my way is the only
way but I believe there should be one voice
that one voice should ring very clear
throughout the film and along the way
because it's a collaborative process there'll be
times when someone will have advice for you that
really makes that moment way more honest than the
one you created and you have to take that advice
as the voice that that advice is good sound advice
but it can't just be shoved into the film because
this guy said so because it can
really take people out of the film
how many screenplays have you written
I have lost count I have lost count um
more than 50 more than 50. I can say that feature
screenplays or a mixture of shorts and features
no those are those will be all features
mixture features mixture of pilots
when did you write your first feature screenplay
maybe about 18 19 and it was it was called
audacious what's the name of it and nobody
understood like what is this and I had to explain
what audacious meant and but it was a vampire
script yeah oh okay and you were in Georgia at
the time I was in Georgia yeah okay and think
at that time I hadn't learned the importance of of
titles titles have to be strong and understandable
and have sometimes a couple of different
meanings they can't just be self-indulgent
and everything I wrote had some weird thing that
i'd learned but that was by far the weirdest title
I think I came up with which was audacious what
does it actually mean to live vicariously through
someone or something like a parasite oh okay yeah
interesting codependency yeah oh okay okay and
that's really what it was about about this vampire
needing this guy to come to fruition to come to be
what was your writing process like on that
first screenplay making sure that the names
were indented properly and making sure spacing
was appropriate and the proper font was being used
I was it was so much still a learning process of
just what went into writing us a screenplay from a
formatting standpoint not a story structure
standpoint so at that point I hadn't even gotten
into really into the craft it was still very
much just how do I make this look professional
so how long did it take you to
finish that screenplay oh five days
oh wow okay five days in the beginning I wrote
screenplays in a week or less in a week because
I didn't know what I didn't know like once you
understand what the craft really is and how
you how you get how you move an audience the
way you need to move them how do you get out
information without it being very convoluted or
heavy-handed how do you how do you get information
across both in text and subtext like once you
start getting into that and story structure it's
it complicates things and there's no way that
you're writing a script in a week and if you do
and it reads very well I'm i'm impressed
I'm impressed because there's a lot of work
that goes into it just in terms of just
outlining takes me about a week or more
just outlining it just to understand what's
going on in a very like one page kind of way
it takes a while so back then I didn't know that
so you when you don't know what you don't know you
just you plow right through it like I'm done you
drop it on the desk and for some reason I think
I think it's all because the industry was so new
to Georgia in the in the late 90s early 2000s like
late 90s really and that's where I really started
to get a lot of work and I'm turning in and stuff
that agent I don't I knew that he'd certainly
represented other writers and but I don't I
don't think he ever represented anybody who
was successful because there's no way you
could if you were receiving those kind
of screenplays and just being like whoa
that's awesome it's there is no structure I look
back sometimes on some of the things I've written
like what was I thinking and it's just because you
you didn't know you don't know what you don't know
and so you're you're constantly learning every
time and especially when you seek knowledge
and you you don't have that vanity to
believe that you're the best at something
I never believe that I'm the best at anything
other than being me that that's really it and
I'm even sometimes struggling with that right
so so I'm constantly looking at ways to improve
and as I began to understand story structure and
stuff like that my stories got better but it took
a while for me to get to the place where I am now
where I feel I feel as though I'm creating very
complete stories where you don't feel at the
end like what no I'm just missing something I
just can't figure out what it is I feel like my
stories are very complete now I feel they tell
a complete story and all the arcs are completed
and they're completed skillfully I'm always just
looking to figure out how to write a better
script the next time how do I how do I write
a better script the next time and then I start
okay I did this last time what do I improve but
what didn't I know that I know now and and that's
how you continue to grow but back then script in a
week was nothing do you think it would have helped
if you had this delusion where you thought your
thing was the greatest or your writing was the
greatest some people they're able to convince
everybody to that somehow I don't know I know
people like that I know people like that and
and don't get me wrong I don't mean I know people
like that who don't work I know people like that
who are working and some of the conversations
I've heard have been hilarious because this person
has I think in the arts because it is it is so
much it is so personal even if it's supposed
to be business it's really personal you create
something it came from you you birthed it right
and then you hear somebody look at two pages
and go that's garbage what else you got
you you either have to be able to
accept it and say that's not for them or
you become calloused and you become you develop a
sense of an inflated ego and I think that if you
if you develop the inflated ego which I think is
the go-to you you start stunting your growth as
a matter of fact i'd venture to say you start
regressing because when the going gets tough
you're gonna fall back on the things and
you've never bothered to learn anything new
you're just gonna fall back on the things that
you think have worked and I see that a lot in
the industry I don't think that's helpful at
all I think I think it's to your detriment
oh and when I say detriment I don't mean detriment
in terms of of your your marketability mean in
terms of your true ability to grow and become your
best you I think it's I think it's detrimental
with autism did you ever try to sell it yes
sadly the the agent did try to sell it and
he tried very hard and I don't blame anybody from
not for not buying it as a matter of fact I have
told this to everyone including my mom who thinks
I'm the absolute best I told my mom I'm absolutely
over the moon that nobody took me seriously in the
beginning because if they had and I had made any
of the number of screenplays that I had written
in the in the past in my in the very beginning
they would have laughed me out of here
and I would have never got another job
I think I would have never reached a point
where I felt as though I could take my career
into my own hands I never would have gotten there
because I think at that age if that happens to you
you're done I think you're done if somebody
if somebody cuts your legs off at 20
I think your legs are just gone I think you don't
have the stomach for it I see too many people that
come to la and they think they're gonna be and
then they get their legs cut out from under them
and they go back to where they came from and they
are no longer interested in the business at all
so I'm very fortunate that nobody
took me serious except that one agent
very serious I think everything happened exactly
how it was supposed to I on the one assignment
that I was sent out on and taken seriously and it
was through a sample not from me writing anything
for that specific pilot it was just from a sample
of my writing in general and that's how I was on
young americans but if it had can you imagine if
I if they have wanted a submission like so a tv
show I've written and I submitted something
it was like yeah here take a look at this
get out of here that's what would have
happened it was too green I didn't know enough
so can you take us all the way
through your writing process
um it's changed a lot before I
think my writing process was more
I had an idea and then I wanted to take a
really good look at the two main characters
and then branch off from there with
and I would always write like random
scenes like these are the must half scenes in
the script because that's what ultimately made
me think about the the the story I carried that
with me for a while but now it's not so much
that and it's because I've i've made enough
films where I know what goes into making one
and just starting at the writing standpoint so
now I only write stories that wake me up in the
middle of the night and make me go grab my laptop
if it doesn't make me do that I don't write it
if there's something that happens and I'm like
what that's it gotta sit down I gotta nail this
and the reason is because as we've spoken about
before that passion if if what you have in here
isn't it it doesn't wake you up in the
middle of the night with for this project
then I don't know how possible it is like you're
gonna have to fight so hard to make it to the end
so for me it starts with does this thing wake me
up in the middle of the night is this the only
thing I can think about right now and if it is the
only thing I can think about what am I thinking
about right now why do I want to write this
what is it saying about me and I start with that
and then what I do is ultimately something
is going on around me that's making me
feel this way and oftentimes it's music so
then that song is on repeat repeat repeat
repeat I'm writing a story right
now called moon and the stars
and it's a story about love but not romantic love
there's romantic love in it but it's more about
the real concept of love like when you really
love someone what you're willing to do for them
what does it really mean for you to really love
someone and believe it or not the I can't get
this story out of my head and I'm already we've
already set it up to start production in 2022
the song that I have on repeat is what is a guy's
name weekend and his song save your tears I don't
know if you've heard that song but I just have
it on repeat and I just write and I write and I
write I'm just so obsessed with the story I'm
so obsessed with the character's journey and
at every time I stop because I always say find the
perfect scene and stop and then when I stop I go
back and I think about all the technical stuff
and I start to make notes for myself okay when
you go back to rewrite make sure you think about
this and think about this and think about this
and then when I sit down the next day to write
it that song goes on and by the way I don't know
if this is a thing for every song but on youtube
you can search the song and loop and then it'll
come up with somebody who's made like a two
hour loop of the same song over and over and
over and I just hit play and I just and I just I
and I know what the objective is for every scene
so I sit down I'm looking through my notes
I'm like okay this is my objective for today
I need to do this for these previous scenes
and then the new scenes have to be about this
it has to be a point to every scene I can't just
sit down like I did before and just write a scene
and hopefully some way find some sort of connect
some kind of connective tissue for the rest
of the story I have to know the point of the scene
and who's making the point and why is this person
the best person to make this point or why is
this event the event that needs to happen now
and I that's how I kind of structure each scene
but I go back and make sure it fits the story as
a whole and I just do that all the way through
when you say that you you what if it wakes you
up in the middle of the night are you already
up for something else and then you're like what
this one part I've just gotta write this down or
how does that work if let's say it's two in the
morning on a tuesday and you just happen to wake
up what's your process are you going to a laptop
it all depends it all depends if I am trying to
not wake up the cat or my wife then it's going
to be going into the into the living room where
my office is and sitting down at the computer
and just but then there'll be times where
maybe I get hit with inspiration at 6 00 a.m
6 a.m and the sun's probably starting to
come up it's okay if I grab the laptop and
from the bed so i'll do it that way but but
usually I feel something and I have to get
up and I have to write and I have to complete
this script and it happens it only happens when
now because I think I've i've allowed
myself to surrender to whatever
that that thing is inside you that
intuition it tells you now is a time
I think that it's well somebody someone said
a while back where writing is a profession and
you have to sit down at the keyboard at a
certain time and then you get up from that
computer at a certain time because it's your job
to write it's your career and you're professional
that's okay get that I get that but if you are
a person who you have multiple films in various
stages of production maybe nine to five isn't
something I can do because I'm still editing this
one I'm still handling the promotional stuff for
this one I'm doing interviews over here for that
one I can't just sit at a computer from nine
to five right so I write when the inspiration
hits me and oftentimes it is in the middle
of the night it's in that moment where you
you kind of wake up or you're about to go to
sleep that little that little area I don't know
what it is about that time but it's like oh there
it is and then you just and you punch you you sit
there and you punch the keypad until you get it
out of your system you purge out of your system
and you go back and you you read it and you make
sure you got everything okay I get everything
okay cool let me write my notes and that's just
my notes for what to do when I come back to it
and how does it tie back into the rest of the
story just making sure that it stays fresh
because when you get that feeling and
you put it on paper you sometimes forget
certain details so you make sure I make sure I
want to write it down and then I go back but yeah
I believe that you you have to surrender to that
that urge that desire to get up right now because
you you you feel that this needs to be on the page
at this moment I don't believe that's something
you can force my best writing has been when I
felt that urge are you sensitive to the moon
I don't know oh okay because you used it's
called moon and stars or whatever oh it's moon
m-u-n-e and stars s-t-a-r-r-s okay and it's really
affecting you yeah no no no it's funny it's it's
a story that when I describe it people go well
where's the love story but it's a story about this
1842 this child she's 66 years old six-year-old
prodigy from beijing and she's taken
through a portal by this guy named igoon and the
order of fanu and they take her to a place where
love wilts and hope goes to die and they
take her here and then the story picks up
in this day and age and there's a guy who's
going through a breakup and he's trying
desperately to get back with his fiance and he's
been having his vision since he was a kid of
various catastrophes and this one
girl is always in his dreams and
one day when he's just at his bottom the
portal opens up and she comes through
and she tells him that he's the only
like the ego and the order for new are
coming to basically destroy life as
we know it and you are the only hope
and the guy who's had no desire to do anything in
his life other than be with this woman over here
now has a new mission in life and ultimately
the woman that he is in love with who
just doesn't want to be with him
right now she's also enlisted to help
him in this fight to save the universe and
throughout all of it what he has to learn is
what what is love truly because
love he thought was showing someone
how much you want to be with them so they'll
want to be with you but truly it's having enough
love for this person to only want the
best for them even if the best for them
isn't you that's all you want is you want to see
the best for this person and that's the lesson
that he's trying to learn throughout this movie
and that's ultimately the lesson that helps him
to be successful at saving
the world in the universe
wow but in all of that that just came from I
don't know what it was it was something happened
and it just made me evaluate love and what we
think of it as as people even healthy people
like what we think about love and I was just
like man so many people have it so backwards
so backwards they or they love a person because
of how the person makes them feel and it's like
that's not love that's it's something but it ain't
love and that's that's what really wakes me up is
whenever I find some other example of it and I'm
like oh why isn't that in the script and then it's
like oh and then this person does this and this
event happens and I'm just constantly jumping
up in the middle of the night or early morning
and plugging in more pages and it's all coming
from a place of of passion but also truth and
and honesty which I believe truth and honesty
are two very different things but it's coming
from a place of truth in a place of honesty and
and building this story and those are the stories
that I'm trying to tell now versus how I used to
tell stories I used to tell stories it was very
stream of consciousness and it was whatever it
was supposed to be and then it was done and now I
put more thought into making sure the stories are
just honest they're coming from an honest place
even if you don't agree with the message even if
you don't agree with the characters it's coming
from a place of honesty yeah I was wondering what
what is the difference between writing honesty and
writing truth in your screenplay I think truth is
a fact honesty is the feeling I think honesty is
your intent okay if you I met many people who are
super honest but their facts are so screwed up
that is not the truth that is not what happened
but you can tell a person truth and not be
honest also you can tell facts and omit certain
things that don't fit your narrative and that's
being dishonest yet you're still being truthful
okay so which would you rather
have in a story truth or honesty
honesty I think
i think honesty inner story is is better
than the truth but aspire to have both
what has to happen in the first 10 minutes of a
horror screenplay I think it depends on the genre
and what you're trying to accomplish but I
think certainly there should be something
that happens in that first 10 minutes that makes
an audience realize holy crap I'm in for a ride
something has to happen in that first
10 minutes that gives you that feeling
and if that doesn't happen I will often times
wonder what we were waiting on that's just like
some a friend of mine he gets onto me because
he's way bigger filming tv buff than I am
and he always says to me like oh you stopped
watching the tv show too soon it got really good
on the fifth episode and I'm like then
why did they wait into the fifth episode
do it from the beginning I do
this for a living you can do it
do it from the beginning I think it
works the same way with with horror films
if in the first 10 minutes you've you've not
told the audience what kind of ride they're on
then you in my book you haven't succeeded in
my book you're setting yourself up to fail
so in the first 10 minutes give them something
give them something to realize holy crap
something's about to go down so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a gory scene it's
just maybe a sense of mystery a sense of something
ominous that's looming yeah I just mean give them
that's why I say depends on the type of film that
it is because there can be it can be a film that
is going to make you feel so uncomfortable so
they give you something at the beginning to let
like what's happening or what the stakes are
or something something that really pulls you
in and lets like I really need to keep watching
this film if you haven't given him the hook
like what's gonna pull them in I don't I don't
know what you're doing really and that goes really
not even just for for horror films but films in
general I think you should give somebody some
indication of of what kind of ride they're on is
it going to be the the disney tea cups that spin
around is it going to be space mountain what
kind of ride are we on so with 70s and 80s
horror you think we took our time really making
it a little more eerie a little more suspenseful
i think people cared more there is
there's this thing that happens when you shoot
film where everybody goes hey this is serious
and I feel that's lost now I feel like people
say if we don't get it right we'll get it again
we'll do it again and we'll do it again we'll do
it again nobody takes it really as serious but
even right now if you tell somebody we're
shooting 35 millimeter film and you show
up and you plop down the film camera
everybody goes hey hey this is serious
and everybody starts taking way more so I don't
know what it is about a film camera that makes
everything more serious but it does and I think
back then that was all you had you only had film
it was just what kind of film are you gonna shoot
with but you only had film and so everybody took
everything very serious and and then two if you
were a small production you had a limited amount
of film most of the time you were shooting
with a bunch of short ends whatever it was
very serious and it was very well thought out and
nothing was shot in an extraneous sense nothing
was shot just in case everything was shot with
a purpose and I think we're missing that today
is that why you love the 80s horror genre oh I
love it for so many reasons but that's one of them
that's one of them I certainly I felt there
was a magic in the 80s I felt it came in at
the late 70s as well but but there was just a
certain magic with the 80s and the way the films
entertained while still taking it all very
seriously and and still really focusing on on the
creative and technical aspects but just really
putting that production value out there making
it feel magical making it feel special feel like
that's that's something that I I've carried with
me in in all of my films trying to make something
special always even when it's a shoestring budget
I've tried to find some sort of way are there
five 80s horror films or late 70s horror films
that you think every horror filmmaker should watch
like salem slide or or any of these stephen king
my favorite is one that when people hear it they
kind of go what is that but evil dead trap I think
everybody should see that I wanted to say it was
I don't know when that one came out I know it
was in the mid to late 80s and it is a completely
insane horror film from japan and it was at a time
when those movies were banned especially ones
that were this that depicted violence and gore
to this extent this guy went hard core okay and
I remember seeing that in where did I see that
film I don't even know where I saw it it's such
such a rare film I forget where I saw it but
I fell in love with it immediately and I've
watched it I don't know how many times I had
to buy it and the only way you could buy it
in the u.s was part of a a big pack of films
where it was evil dead trap because
that's the only one I really really watch
and then it was another one called like entrails
of a virgin oh yeah yeah it's just they're so
bizarre but yet you could tell when the film is
made it's made with love this guy loved the genre
he loved this was before gore gross out was
a thing before gore it was people think about
like the mutilator that movie and which not a
great movie but the thing about it was was it
had some decent gore and the positions that they
put people in even when they didn't show it when
it was just implied you were like ah but nobody
had taken it to the extent that this guy did
I think his name is was it toshi toshiharu
ikita is his name and the visuals of that
movie are just so disturbing but I look
at that film as being my top horror film
ones that influenced me yes now if you start
getting into others that people should see
do you mean like top hard top just films in
general it's all hard because it just seemed
like there was a creepiness factor that really
took time to build yeah and and I really love that
of the that era not so much the gore yeah
absolutely this one had this one had the gore
came in much later but it did have the the creepy
effect speaking of evil dead trap it did it if
you haven't seen it please see it it's I endorse
this film okay my name is josten yes and I approve
this message now if you're if you're moving away
from that you have to like right next to that put
halloween the original halloween now that one
is not 80s that one's late 70s I think that's
like 78 or 79 but that's what I meant by late 70s
early 80s that time period so I would definitely
put halloween on that list I think they they got
busy quick they let you knew let they let what
type of movie you were in they had a summer camp
feel but in someone's house which was pretty easy
pretty interesting really loved that about the
film I think he took his time and he didn't try
to rush anything in the film but you understood
in that first 10 minutes what kind of movie you
were watching it wasn't a mystery it wasn't a
mystery I think once you once you leave that one
I want to I want to stay more in the
more accessible range so I would say
if I if I'm going with what's more accessible I
would then lean towards your your hellraisers I
think hellraiser was very creative for his time I
don't think anybody really kind of got into that
aspect yet of making your making who would
normally be a villain kind of an anti-hero
so I thought that was pretty
cool that was pretty clever
and from there I jump into to your
your jason's and your freddie kruegers
yeah what about the use I don't know if this would
be horror tropes but let's say the the late night
phone call and no one's there yeah like what
what are some of the things that are just tried
and true that they always work it doesn't matter
what year this is just it just builds an intrigue
I think that shot from behind when a person is
walking through a house and the camera is drifting
behind them and then they stop and the camera's
slowly getting closer okay because you're like
oh my god what's gonna happen I think that always
works and that never gets old and nobody ever says
why that's tired nobody ever says that because
it's just the movement of a camera I think once
you get into actions that's where it gets kind
of tropey I think when you get into the late
night phone call I think when you get into the
oh my gosh it's so hot let me take my clothes off
and then you see the hand reach in and take the
clothes away and it's like oh that's not the
killer that's their friend this is like oh come on
like a lot of those things think they get really
tropey but I think the the camera tricks are the
things that don't get old I don't like the jumpy
things I don't really like those so much those are
boring to me mainly because I don't jump but like
to be creeped out I like to end the movie and like
go should I turn off the light I want that feeling
but I think the whole camera moving
behind someone I love rosemary's baby
when the camera kind of shifts a little and
you're constantly thinking something's about
to happen to her just because the camera moved
a little I like little subtle things like that
I think those are still very effective they'll
never go away should something scary happen on
page one of a horror film or is it better
to wait a little bit if it fits the story
it's all about what fits the story and what story
you're trying to tell if if you get right to it
on page one hey bravo I hope that you don't take
your foot off the gas because now you've built up
expectation because I think you said in the last
question that halloween they let fairly quickly
what was going on is that something that did
they maintain it it's been a while sorry so oh
yeah but but mainly because halloween wasn't
it wasn't a story about a guy in a mask
who was just killing people at random like that
wasn't the story it was a story of evil and evil
started young and this kid was full of evil and
so as he when he grew up and he came home it was
like what is this guy going to do now and he was
stalking jamie lee's curtis character and you
always knew it was that it was that that sense of
it did you ever see what was that movie it follows
and it was the girl has sex with the guy and
then the evil spirit starts following her and
if it catches her it'll kill her that sort of
thing right so the thing about it was it moved
slow but it was always present and it was always
closing in so even if it was far behind you knew
you had to stay that much ahead of it right you
knew in this movie jamie lee curtis didn't know
only the audience knew that he was closing in
on her he's getting closer and closer and close
and that's where the dread came from
that's why in the beginning of the film
when we see him as a kid and we see him like he's
actually going about murdering his sister and the
sister's boyfriend and all that stuff it was the
build up of this evil that was inside this kid
and he slowly worked his way up to that in those
first 10 minutes right and then he grew up and now
you're watching it play out as an adult so he
he built he set the tone for what the rest of
the film was going to be and he didn't really let
up all he did was give you someone to care about
in jamie lee curtis's character laurie strode he
gave you somebody to care about and then he said
now watch me butcher her and then you were like
you were so worried for it you were like please
run he's right there and I think he did that very
very well sure and it would be the same I guess
in the exorcist as well even though the character
wasn't stalking her it was inside of her and she
couldn't she couldn't get it out she couldn't stop
it yeah you set the tone very early with that one
they said an eerie tone when they were digging
up they're excavating the thing and it was it
just felt weird the musical cues the zooms all
of it felt weird all of it felt very very weird
and they kept that feeling throughout it just kept
you off balance it kept you really off balance it
made your skin crawl a little bit right yeah it
was great how often have you read a screenplay
where nothing happens in the first 10 minutes
no scares nothing all too often all too often um
i think that because the software now
can format things for you and everybody
learns about final draft or or movie magic or
whatever they learn about these these different
programs it's easy to make your screenplay
look professional it's only when you
start to read it do you do you understand the
level of craft that they're at right now right and
in certain levels of craft there's always that oh
we're building to something great we're building
to something great and that's at a certain
level right and they may be really really good
at crafting a story and dialogue and things may
seem okay but if nothing is happening and nothing
is happening by page 10 nothing is happening by
page 15 but page 20 when is something gonna happen
I do I do read a lot of scripts where I wonder
that or I wonder what is the point what is the
point what are you trying to say even if you
have nothing to say what is the point of the film
who's your hero what is this person going
through how does going through this change them
how does going through this and them changing
help them deal with the true protect antagonist
all those things all those questions they aren't
answered because they aren't at that level yet
you know so you're gonna get a mismatch
but for the most part I would say out of
if I read
10 screenplays
something happens by page 10
in one of them depending upon which week
it is not every time does something happen
not all the time does it sometimes
it might be one of the 20 screenplays
what if someone says well I want to take my time
with the suspense if you look back at the step for
wives and I realize that's not really horror it's
more like thriller it was a long intro to them
coming to this new neighborhood and seeing these
wives and and she's kind of confused about what's
going on it took its time yeah but the thing about
it is it establishes its tone very quickly and I
feel like that's another thing that's missing
because so many people haven't found their voice
how they tell a story right because
your story may change depending upon
whatever genre you've decided
to write today whatever
got into you like this love story that I wanted
that I'm writing right now moon in the stars it's
a it's people hear me say it's a love story and
you think oh romantic drama and I'm like actually
no it's a sci-fi it's a sci-fi these people are
interstellar travelers interdimensional travelers
time travelers and they can do this and they can
do that and like but then where's the love portion
well the love portions here and it's but it's a
completely different thing than I've ever written
once in one is a very completely different
story than I've ever written I think that
people classify that one as a suspense drama
or drama thriller or something like that so and
that's very different than the horror that I've
directed and even within the horror I've directed
many different types of horror so no matter what
the genre is that you're writing in you have to
at some point have developed your voice and how
how how a person recognizes that it's your film
right and then once you start to develop your
voice I think it'll help you drastically with
maintaining tone of a film because your voice
is your voice and it's how you tell the story
and as long as you understand the tone of your
own film you can keep that modulated all the
way through and you can set that at the very
beginning then once you set that tone like this
is where this story takes place in this
type of world you start that from page one
you start it from page one so yes nothing may
happen in terms of someone getting murdered
or whatever you may not get the horror in the
because it may not be a horror maybe it's just a
movie that's meant to make you squirm and make you
uncomfortable maybe that's what it is or maybe the
story is speaking to like with once and one it was
about a guy who didn't even know himself anymore
so if he doesn't know himself he doesn't even
recognize himself in certain situations and if
you tell him he's done something wrong he's
relying on your truth to tell him he's done
something wrong because he doesn't even
know right and wrong of himself anymore
and I showed that from page one if you can't
even recognize who you are and what you do in
the situation when someone tells you to make
it better how can you he's like how do I how
do I do it and the person has to tell him I think
that's something you can figure out and he's like
well I don't think he can he really can't
it sets the tone for the film nobody died
nobody was hunted down in the first 10 pages
I just set the tone for for what the story is
and I think that that's once you it takes
a while before you get to that level of
understanding of of what you're doing and then
I think now you've gotten to a point where
technically you're proficient but you still have
so much more like so many more levels to climb
do you think it's better that someone rushes
into a more of a horrific scene or takes their
time like which which is more detrimental to a
horror script too long to get into the action
or too fast again think it depends
on the the point of the story
I think that scream which is one of my faves from
the 90s it in the first film it kind of meanders
right at first in the first like minute or two
she picks up the phone she's talking to the guy
and making popcorn everything
seems fine it seems very casual
it's not until the first kind of slip up
that she doesn't hear that we heard is the
audience that we realize wait a minute and
then you start to you start to sit forward
right the story is about a guy who calls you on
the phone he stabs you to death we didn't see that
until like it came in probably around the five
minute mark is when we started to be concerned
right so in that first five minutes it's like are
we just following this lady and if you notice that
movie is really for the longest time it's a single
shot it's a single shot she picks up the phone and
they pull away from the phone they're following
her around into the kitchen it's a single shot
for a lot of it and even when they abandon
it they pick it up on another another winner
and they're walking around and it's masterfully
done but it's all about the pacing and the tone
and it slowly becomes more menacing and
once it becomes menacing it never lets up
and so again less about dialogue and more about
camera movement camera movement and just really
understanding tone I think lighting plays an
incredible cinematography in general plays
an incredible role in creating tone your
cinematography your editing post-production
sound musical cues sound effect all that stuff
plays a huge role in it but when you're reading
it on the page when you're on the page it has
something has to set the tone for me to understand
why I should care and a lot of the times I ask
why should I care very early i'll ask that on page
sometimes too i'll ask why should I care now
something may not happen until page three or
page four but i'll be asking myself why do I care
when I watch movies at home i'll turn them on
i'll watch for a little bit but then i'll turn it
because there's so much content that's available
right now why would I waste time I treat a
movie that I'm watching just like I would a
script that I'm reading I start watching and if
it's not catching my attention I have to abandon
I have to abandon it yeah I think it was harder
before because there was so little you couldn't
check a phone you couldn't have one window open
and be over here you had to you were just like all
right i'll let it play and sometimes that worked
with advantage because then it grew on you but now
you have to catch people that's what I was asking
if you knew the analytics of when people dropped
out or if people rewound a scene or something yeah
I don't have it like in terms of analytics from
from amazon I don't I don't have it when someone
maybe rewinds it or something I don't have that
but I do know I can tell the progression like
people are dropping out dropping out dropping
out dropping out oh it stabilized and then
people watched it all the way through here
and then it dropped out like I can tell that
but I can't really tell did they pause it
and then go do something and come back like I
can't tell those sort of things or that they
rewind you can't really see that but the the thing
about it is is that I usually will start my films
and I try to get them to a point where you
don't feel there's a place to jump off because
something's always building to something
else and one scene leads into the next
very naturally so I'm constantly trying to do
that so it doesn't feel like there's a place to
really drop off or you'll feel like you're missing
something because something just happened so now
I have to see how that affects the next thing I'm
constantly trying to to keep that momentum going
and I think that's what you you have to do or
what you should aspire to do when you're doing
anything something it always has to be building
towards something or what else are we doing
why why would I be investing my time if if
nothing in your script is investing towards
something bigger so a bigger character goal or a
bigger scare or or something with the antagonist
yeah set up your stakes give me a character
who's who's interesting that I care about
even if you don't want to root for them to succeed
root for them to not succeed something give the
audience something to to to to keep them invested
and keep them interested and it does start with
having something in the first few pages whether
it's tone whether it's an act of whatever that
drives the story forward give them something that
keeps them watching more importantly something
that lets them know what kind of a ride they're
on sure because even with hereditary we didn't
totally know we just knew something ominous yes
was there and it kind of keeps you on the edge
and you didn't know what was it though yeah and
the great thing about hereditary right now is if
if you if we talk about hereditary the first thing
we do is go hereditary we went just thinking about
it right but if you if you go back and you think
like what do I remember from the film I remember
there was this like little sibling thing with
the brother and the sister I remember her head
hit that pole and it came off and then I remember
he didn't want to like he just parked the car and
went into the house I remember the thing from
him in the classroom where his face kind of
went crazy and he slammed his head on the desk and
stuff I remember that and then I remember all the
stuff that happened at the end with him with the
mother and the father bursting into flames and all
that stuff and the mom banging her head but we're
recalling just these few moments but the fact is
is that we made it to the end in complete
terror because of the tone of the film
the tone was set very early and they never let up
even when they had moments where it looked like
hope was starting to shine in through the window
it didn't matter the tone was so dark and
ominous and heavy that you just you felt like oh
and you felt cold I don't know if
about you I felt cold watching it
it was it was such a weird feeling that you got
watching that movie but they kept that tone up
throughout the entire film and that's what
is it's finding your tone and staying with it
very early something that makes people
care and make them keep watching
how much punishment should we put our main
character through well I think somebody
described it best when they said the what
you do to make someone what a story is is
people chasing a character up a tree and throwing
rocks at them while they're trying to climb down
that's ultimately what a story is right and
so I think that you should put them through as
much punishment as they can weather and
still realistically want to pursue their goal
and still realistically understand the stakes one
of my favorite shows is the walking dead right and
there was a period in episode oh in season seven
was it seven or eight may have been season seven
and people kind of stopped watching it went like
this and mainly it was due to how much punishment
they put the main character through he had so
much punishment heaped upon him that his only goal
was not to receive more punishment that
his people would receive no more punishment
and this was from a character who had been a a
world beater for six seasons and all of a sudden
we're watching him not only be beaten but to just
be beaten to a point where the fight is beaten out
of them and I think people jumped off because that
was the point that the punishment went too far
that was the point where audience was like okay
I'm tapping out I can't do it anymore there was
there was I remember there was an episode where
he just stood there like it was just one locked
off shot of him and he just cried and the camera
went to a wide shot and he's just completely alone
and he's crying and there's a guy who he just
watched be killed that was from his community
and the guy turns into a zombie so it's even
worse now he's had a freaking after he just
witnessed this happen to the guy and he could
do nothing about it he had to turn around and
be the person to right through the brain to put
him out of his misery like think I still kept
watching of course because it's one of my favorite
shows but I can understand why people jumped off
because at that point punishment went too far so
I think it's it has to be enough punishment where
it does create the wound that
we're all looking for him to heal
but it can't be so much that if it makes him
forget the goal the goal was not to not to receive
more punishment the goal was to keep his people
safe and get rid of all threats and now he's not
trying to get rid of the threat he's trying to
live with the threat and he fears the threat
and I think that's too much for audiences to to
deal with we have to constantly keep this guy
moving forward and working towards his goal while
all the time realizing he could probably lose
he could probably lose but will root for him if he
keeps pursuing his goal so it was the fact that we
saw the fight beaten out of him not the that not
him being put through the fight well he there was
no fight he was being punished and punished and
punished and punished it was it was so have you
seen this seasons if you haven't seen season
seven it's it starts with him on his knees
because that's how the season six ended with him
on his knees so it starts with him on his knees
and watching two of his friends and he could
do nothing about it they're told if you move
we'll kill everybody but for right now we're
just gonna kill this one guy in front of you
all and they proceed to beat this guy's head in
with a baseball bat in front of all his friends
and another guy can't take it anymore he gets
up and hits the bad guy and the bad guy says
that's going to cost you because now I'm going
to beat another guy head in and he beats another
guy's head in all the while the leader has
to watch this happen and he can do nothing
he starts the season on his knees watching
his friends die and there's nothing he can do
and then for the rest of that season he's met
with even more punishment and more punishment
and the threat is always if you don't do
what we say and you don't give us what
we want we'll show up and kill everybody
don't forget that and it's like how many
times can you see that and how many times
can you see that and the good guy not say
that's it we got to come up with a plan his only
plan is to make sure there's not more punishment
you can't you can't do that to audiences they
have to see the fight they have to see the
struggle they have to see you trying to win
not being complacent with being proud beaten
would you say the more punishment we put our
protagonist through the better the story is going
to be to a certain extent yes to a certain extent
as long as we don't put them through too much
I think that we have to see for my stories I
love to to to show the person show their wound
and then show how they've begin to live with
this wound by accepting it as a truth even
though it's a false truth and how their world
is with that right now this person may not be
down on their luck or anything but something
has happened and this is told them that this
is the way you live life right and there has to
be something that forces them on their journey
when they start going on their
journey they can't win every little
battle they gotta lose but they gotta see
that what but I can see on the other side
of it if I just keep going because this these
are the stakes and I can't allow myself to lose
they have to take enough punishment along the
way where you you keep believing in them even
if they don't they don't really believe in
themselves and then it has to get to a point
where it's a soul-crushing defeat like right when
they thought they won it's a soul-crushing defeat
and you got to watch them pick up the pieces
and you got to fill you got to that's when you
circle the wagons and you're bringing together
all the different people that are gonna help you
build build the character back up and put
them back on their their journey because now
they realize this is the worst that it can get
this is the worst that this guy can do to me
but the stakes are still the stakes I still have
to stop this thing from happening whatever it is
right so they've absorbed all this punishment
and they realize that's the worst that it can get
so this guy cannot hurt me any more than this
only by them succeeding at their goal so now
I'm just going to go straight after them
straight away now there's many different
ways of what you can do to get them to stop the
bad guy or the bad guy succeeds or whatever but
at this point that's when the audience is
behind them they receive enough punishment where
they have hopefully garnered the sympathy of
the audience and the audience is behind them
so that when they lead them into this final
battle the audience is right behind them right
on the horse right behind them like oh and you're
you're watching this person go in and save the day
now if you give them too much punishment I
think the audience can bail because they're
just I've seen it happen they just bailed I
don't think you can watch a person just lose
I don't think you can watch them just lose
they have to have some win somewhere what
are ways that a writer can create high stakes
for their character ooh it's a good question um
it has to be well first of all it has to
be something that relates to their wound
right it has to be some kink in their armor
where this makes it personal for them it has to
be that that's number one and because overall
the story is about them overcoming that wound
and that's somehow tying into this goal
of stopping whatever the antagonist is
so but the stakes have to be high enough where it
almost seems insurmountable so yeah I believe that
the stakes are very important but it has to be
all relatable to the character into the audience
okay so if it's something that's too avant-garde
we can't understand it but if it's just sort of
about the basic needs of living safety security
then we can relate to it I think it can be
almost anything it all depends on who
you are who your core audience is for
just giving example for once and one
right if you if you watch the film
it's very easy to sit back and go I what I
don't really get it but the story is very meta
it's very meta this there's a story happening and
then there's a story that the writer is writing
but unbeknownst to him they both are the
same story okay and in the story that he's
trying to write that he's having writer's
block with the reason why he can't relate
is because he's cut so many pieces of himself
away to fit in right to fit in with this
life with his wife this new Hollywood life he was
doing it before when he was trying to do sales
he's just trying to fit in with everybody with his
friends he keeps cutting off pieces of himself to
the point where he doesn't recognize himself
anymore okay and he's not honest with himself
without honesty and he doesn't know
himself he doesn't even know what he wants
he's writing a script that he can't he can't
finish it it seems convoluted there's all
this other stuff going on inside the story that
he's writing is about a guy who's robbing a bank
he wants the money then there's his
girl that he meets inside of the bank
he starts falling for the girl there's the police
outside the police are going to make him pay for
whatever he does right if he wants the girl he
has to give up the money because she doesn't
like stealing and all that other kind of
stuff if he takes the money he loses the
girl and all of that the police are still
outside how is he going to get past that
in both of these stories it's not even knowing
what the guy wants the guy doesn't know what he
wants he's all over the place right and what
you begin to realize is for the protagonist
and the story his wife is really related to
the money in the story that's his security
he's so secure with his wife because she's on
a sole property she makes lots of money he can
be a struggling writer and it doesn't matter so he
has that in the movie that's money that's security
right and then he meets this girl named pia and
he's completely infatuated by her it's exciting
and it's new well that's the girl in the story
it's exciting and it's new he's always needed
money and security but excitement has taken over
does he choose excitement and then of course the
woman's husband who's his best friend is the
police that's the people who are going to hold
him accountable they're going to he he's going
to he's going to have to suffer a consequence
whether it's good or bad he's got to suffer a
consequence that friend is going to make him pay
he's making him pay the whole movie when you're
watching you're just like geez you almost consider
the friend to be the bad guy until you realize
this guy has a wife but he's infatuated
with this other woman right and that's the
dance that is going on in this entire film
so I look at it and I go the film may be hard
to understand it may be hard to understand how
to relate to it and how this relates to you but
for a specific group of people they'll understand
that desire to fit in and that you don't even
know yourself and that you're driven by what
you want in the moment but do you even really want
it do yourself enough to know you really want it
and I think there is a segment of of audiences
that can relate but then there'll also be a
segment that'll say I don't even get any of this
and it's because they don't relate to any of it
they just don't but that movie's not for them
sure or maybe they've seen that in someone close
to them or or they used to be that and then
they realize all that's empty but but see what
you mean someone that's really conflicted they
want what they want they're willing to kind of
sell their soul for it yeah yeah I think that's
a that's a good story to write about Hollywood
mm-hmm it is and it's him he's he's he's just in
the wind because he doesn't know himself anymore
sure he doesn't how long did it take you to
write the script I started writing it in probably
2017 2018 I started writing it but
it was one of those ones where I just
kind of plugged away at it for a little bit at
a time and then I got to a point where I said
don't know where I should take this story and
then what happened was I put it aside for a moment
and I went off and I did some other work and
it was around that time that I realized man
the reason why I didn't know where to go
with this story was because I was trying to
stick a Hollywood ending on it and it's
funny because that's actually a line
in the earlier in the script is that he was saying
he's taking advice from the character p and he
says I can't take that advice because it's not
a very Hollywood ending and she tells him well
Hollywood ending all depends on where you stop the
story and so said to myself I have to be honest in
the rest of the screenplay I have to be honest and
I have to make him have real conversations about
where he's headed where his relationships
are headed where his life is headed
he has to have these real conversations now
he can't have them the way that we have them
but he has to have them and he has to make a
decision it can't be ambiguous he has to make
a decision and so once I went back into the script
with that mandate I was able to wrap it up pretty
quickly I was going to rep it pretty quickly and
pretty honestly and with as much truth as possible
did you give the script to
many people for feedback no no
think feedback is great sometimes
but when it's something that's very
it was very new for me to be that honest
and not truthful and not try to stick
like Hollywood stuff into Hollywood
magic to make it magically resolve
I didn't want that type of feedback I
wanted I wanted it to exist for what it was
so you didn't need to get notes from
anybody because you self-financed it
and so you just knew you were but were
there any parts that maybe were unclear
that you wanted people to see and flesh out for
the characters or no you just knew we were going
to do it this one way I knew I was going to do
it that one way what I did was once I got actors
on board who were very very talented and they
were very outspoken about their own thoughts on it
I was able to just have a conversation with
them where I said free like there are no
wrong answers okay but we're just going to sit
down and we're going to talk about the script
and we're going to talk about the moments and
how we can make them honest and very truthful
so let's have those conversations and like I
said it was very productive because no one was
saying but I think it should end this way or
I think it should establish very early on the
theme of the movie and where it's headed is not
changing how we get there may adjust a little bit
but where this train is headed it already left
the station and it's headed to this destination
so we all sat down and we said okay cool
in these moments here are things that we
can do to make it more truthful and make it feel
more honest and that's really what we focused on
so there were some changes along
the way but for the most part
what was on the page was on the screen for the
most part I got I got very very close I would say
i would say I was 75 there 75 of what I wanted
is on the screen which is a high number for me
what do you tell other screenwriters filmmakers
about being too precious about certain scenes
that maybe they just don't totally serve the
story I haven't had to have that conversation
however that conversation was had with
me and it was had by eddie watkins
he told me he said your biggest problem is
that you're married to everything you do
you can't be that way especially if you're
not the one financing and directing it
you can't be things are going to have to change
for whatever reason and you're going to have
to be open to making whatever those changes are
work and that's what I would tell anybody who's
treating it too precious so because we all
like want certain scenes or some little
artifact in the film and it means something
to us but the audience might not care
and and so when people have given you those
notes or maybe it was just ed are you open to
changing them or has it been hard for you to
take notes and to remove certain things um
in the past
i would say I was probably more open to
removing it even if I didn't agree i'd remove
it because I want this issue to die and I don't
want things to keep carrying over or whatever but
once I started to just kind of stand up and say
no this is this is my film even if you pay for
it it's my film because ultimately nobody's going
to say well I looked at this movie that producer
must have been great that's not what they're
going to say they're going to say the director
and the writer and the cast were great that's
what they're going to say and if people know a
little bit more about the industry they're
going to say the cinematographer was great
but what they're not going to say is wow that
producer really knows his stuff that just doesn't
happen and so what happened is is that we made
the film and we always understood what it was
supposed to be and then as we got further along
people's ego started to get involved and even
though I would explain I understand that this is
great for you but we are at service to the story
not to you so the person would relent and so as
we got further into editing the conversations
would come up again well I think we should
really add this and I'm like you're serving
your own ego you're not really serving the
story so no I don't think we should do that
and so we would go have a little bit back
and forth until I would just say okay what
just so we can be done with it and then you
would cut it and before it it was a movie
that was granted at 2 hours and 15 minutes it's
a bit long so we we cut it down to about maybe
an hour 45 minutes so now it's cut down
only that needs to happen is color and a
little bit of sound working and it's ready
to be done so I hand it off and ultimately
I heard through the grapevine that the film was
finished and that it was at an hour and a half
it's really weird it's really weird
something and it was because I have to take
accountability and responsibility I handed
off the film along with all the footage
so that it could have the
finishing touches put on it
and what ultimately happened was this person
decided to put all these scenes back in and
remove all these other scenes so that their work
would stand out a bit more and it was an ego thing
and I said what dropped the ball on that one
because I gave that person the ability to do
it that was that was my fault and it'll never
happen again it'll never happen again because
that film floats around and people say wow that
film and can't take I can't take credit for the
good or the bad because it's not my film it's not
and that was because I started in the beginning
talked about the tv show 24. and
jack bauer when the guy says ah
you've never done anything bad you've never made
a bad decision you've never just done this one
little thing and he says no because once you do
that one little thing it makes it easier to do
the second thing and the third thing and that
one thing that I did was that I compromised and
I did it just so that the conversation would
die I said ah just and I gave in a little
and a little bit more and a little bit more and
then eventually the film completely changed and
I said I just won't allow that to happen again if
I do work with someone else the film that they'll
receive to do any type of finishing touches which
by the way i'll do them all in house so that when
I hand it off it's a finished film but let's just
say that I had to hand it off they would only get
the film to work with and that would be it because
it's my responsibility to make sure that we're
honest to the film and what the film is trying to
say we're in service of the film not to our egos
we had this comment come in on our channel in a
horror movie only the villain character matters
all the other characters are expendable most are
going to die anyway what's your reaction to that
I don't think that's true if if no one
matters they shouldn't be in the film
if it's only about that villain then he
should be yo-yoing or doing something else
that only requires him I think that you're
trying to tell a story and every character
is integral to that story or they shouldn't
be there maybe that comes from me working
with limited budgets always and you're constantly
saying why is this person here does this person
need to be here because they're going to impact
me and as far as scheduling as far as the budget
and it helps you hone your screenwriting
skills better too because there's nothing
extraneous about the script so to say at
any stage that none of these people matter
I think if you're watching the later friday
the 13th movies if you're watching the later
freddy movies or the later halloweens but if
you're watching the ones that they started with
you would not say anybody was
extraneous in those stories
they that's when they were still very creative
and they had spent a lot of time working on
the script and they gave a lot of thought
towards it and it was written with love and
when you do that when the screenwriter loves those
characters there's no way they will be creating
people that don't matter it's no way how
does a villain in a story reflect the hero
oof if you had asked me this a long time ago now I
say sometimes my villain and my my hero are almost
one in the same they have to pursue whatever
their goal is with the same amount of passion
I think that one person learns lessons and the
other person doesn't and that's ultimately what
does in the villain and the villain has to reflect
whatever it is or I shouldn't say that villain has
reflected but their goal has to reflect something
that the hero is trying to work through so that
they can work through there's a catharsis as they
go through this journey and get to the end and
stop this thing from happening I think that's the
way that it should go but think that they should
both pursue their goals with the same passion and
intensity because that's what makes for a great
villain I still consider the best villain to be
alan rickman's character in die hard I think he
is the best villain ever because his goal is is
the opposite but they're working towards the same
thing which is him and john mclean it's just that
they're going about it differently but they're
both after this their goals with the same amount
of passion and intensity and being clever they're
both very clever that's the other thing about it
like both both of them are trying to one-up the
other one and get one over on the other and that's
what's so compelling about watching that story
I think it should be the same with with any movie
that you're working on whoever is your antagonist
should be going after with the same
amount of intensity and passion
they should be almost a mere reflection of the
of the good guy if maybe they made all the wrong
decisions in the past maybe they didn't make
that 51 percent that warren buffett talks about
maybe they only made the 49 and they they weren't
successful at certain things should the antagonist
be twice as strong as the hero no I think that
the villain should always have an advantage and
most of the time if if you think about it if you
using alan rickman's character in in die hard
his advantage was that he already
knew what he was trying to accomplish
that was his advantage he knew what he was trying
to accomplish and because people would say oh
well he had the numbers too he had all these guys
with guns yeah but they didn't know who they were
looking for and they didn't know where he was
so that put them put them at a disadvantage the
advantage of the good guy the bad guy actually had
the villain was that he knew what he was trying to
accomplish and john mclean had to figure it out so
think I don't think he has to be twice as strong
he just needs to be ahead of the game and the good
guys playing catch up but you say in the in the
end that the antagonist doesn't learn any lessons
but the hero does so the the antagonist is just
it's just all anger it's all trying to get
revenge but the hero somehow learns something
the hero has to learn something he really does
the villain I don't think it has to be about anger
I there have been many villains that have done
things give you an example moon and the stars
my villain isn't a guy who's really trying to kill
everybody as a matter of fact he's trying to save
everyone he's just going about it in a really
bad way what he started to notice he's been to
the edge of the universe and back he's been to
the beginning of time in the end and what he's
seen is that every civilization every leap every
technological leap they make gets them closer and
closer to oblivion what drives those technological
leaps is hope hope hope that things can be better
hope that this makes the world a better place
hope that this gets us to here and hope that
this gets us to there and what we don't account
for is what happens when we make those very when
we make those mistakes or when somebody takes
what we were using for hope and they weaponize it
those are the things that don't get accounted
for so what his idea is is to create a machine
that it shrinks this olympic area in the brain so
that hope dies the problem is when hope dies so
does ambition so there's love so this fear so many
other emotions die and what what happens after
that is that his project showed success right it
and people had no hope but then what happened is
whether it was a day later or a month
later people would off themselves
and if they didn't off themselves they became
something different and it became very much
like the order of fenu that he that
works with him to do these things
so his goal is not one that's out of anger it's
one that's out of love and you find out that it's
to save the people that he still cares about
because he's seen what happens in the future
so he needs this to work now the good guys know
if you do this it's the same as a death sentence
because it's a ticking time bomb for people
just offing themselves just killing themselves
so he's working just as hard to
keep this guy from succeeding
so I don't I don't think it has to be anger or
hatred or or any of those things it just has to
be a goal that they really believe in that they
are just they've given everything there is no
plan b there is only plan a both people have
a plan a and what do you do when they're just
ah they're about to collide that's where the
drama comes from that's where it gets interesting
and if your bad guy was only driven by revenge
I've seen that a million times driven by anger you
can beat the anger out of somebody I've seen it
happen a million times get into a boxing ring and
this guy is angry he won't have all that in three
rounds because he's gonna swing for the fences
he'll be exhausted and you can beat the anger out
of him and he'll give up because that's all he
had was anger so the most compelling stories come
from the people who really believe in their goal
and they're willing to die for their goal what
makes the villain fail is their inability to grow
and adapt because adaptation is survival right
and the good guy figures it out they when they're
beaten in that into the second act when they're
beaten they have to pick up the pieces and learn
their lesson and they're like I still have the
same goal I just got to go about it differently
and the bad guy thinking that he's one already
when he sees the bad guy show up again what
does he do the same exact thing he did to
win last time and that's why he loses why
is evil important in storytelling I think it
depends on the definition of evil I think that
sometimes people will say evil is like oh they do
these horrible things and like if somebody takes
it just as an example and I'm not defending at
all but let's say they take someone like hitler
right and they say you see all the horrible things
he did just evil I go I think he's despicable
i think the atrocities are evil but
true evil is doing it just because
that's true evil he didn't do it just because he
did it because he believed this and he believed
that and he believed this crazy stuff and
he was like the only way to do it is to do
this to me true evil is something that is
is birthed rotten and it has no reason to
exist other than to cause you harm true evil
is terrifying true evil doesn't need a reason
it just doesn't michael myers did not need a
reason that's what made him so terrifying nothing
happened to make him stab his sister and her
boyfriend to death nothing happened that's scary
I think you very rarely though see true evil in
movies because it's something hard to capture
it's something really hard to capture
people that just do things because why not
those are the things that I think in
in reality scare the crap out of me
when you hear about this serial killer
who should you ask why did you do this
why not that's evil that's terrifying but it's
really rarely portrayed very well in films how do
you create a powerful and meaningful story I think
it first has to be powerful and meaningful to you
try to now as I write if I'm writing something
that I story I just have to tell it has to a
lot of the time speak to something maybe that I'm
dealing with myself and I get I can work through
a lot of it in the script and I think that's
why it wakes me up because it's something that
I'm figuring out that I'm working through
and I'm working through it with characters
so I think it starts there it has to be important
and impactful for you and from there you can
begin to shape it so that it's something that is
easily digestible for somebody who's maybe not
experiencing the same things as you or they're not
going on that same journey with you so you want to
make it more relatable so that they can certainly
see that journey and take that journey with you
what if someone asked you to write a screenplay
and for hire and it's not a story that necessarily
you tap into but you're being paid
well and you say all right i'll do it
but you just can't relate to the character
to the story to the theme to the tone
funny enough that just happened and ultimately we
long story short we just couldn't work together
that's just what it was oh wow okay the the
story was just something I can't relate to
and the way I would have to be able to tell the
story that other person who was the financier
they didn't they didn't want the story to go
that direction so we were at an impasse and
we both had to say I don't think this is going
to work for either of us because what you want
won't wake me up in the middle of the night that
message is not a message that speaks to me it's
not a it's a throwaway message and I wouldn't want
to create something that and spend months working
on something that I don't believe in I just I
wouldn't want to do that to myself and I wouldn't
want to do that to someone who's paying me the
money to do it I just I think it's a bad idea
so yeah that actually happened to me recently
and did fairly soon into you're working with
the person that this wasn't going to work this
is going to happen I didn't know it early enough
I allowed us to go down the road too
far and waste a lot of each other's time
and I normally don't consider something
to be a waste of time if I learn a lesson
but I think I learned I think I understood
things far sooner and I just let it drag on
because I believed at some point he would see
what I was saying and as he began to speak with
his partners they would see what I was saying
but unfortunately much like me he didn't have
he did have partners but they were out of the way
they didn't have any influence on the project so
their opinions didn't matter so we're
both people who don't report to anybody
so we both we had to just shake
hands and say it's not going to work
that's fair yeah it's better that you cut
your ties then than actually had it made and
it wasn't exactly what you felt well I wouldn't
have been able to write it I just I think that
when you when you sit down to write something
you you understand that it's a journey right
and for some people it's not about the it's not
about the destination it's just the journey but
I'm constantly keeping both in in mind the journey
and the destination journey and the destination
so I know if this is the destination we agreed to
to get to this is the best path to tell the story
and if that doesn't work and I see the
alternative is an inferior version to that then
have to say I don't think it's gonna click I
don't think it's really gonna click because that
journey won't tell it won't be honest it won't
be honest it's it's forcing something and um
i I don't want to say that but but it's just
it becomes it becomes like you're just pushing
constantly and trying to force something
trying to force a circle in the square hole
and you shouldn't do that when you're writing
especially in the beginning you shouldn't do
that when you're developing the screenplay that's
when it's fun and that's when it's breezy and if
you can't see the journey in a fun and breezy way
then it's time to kind of cut bait don't don't
spend so much time working on it for something
that's it's not going to be fruitful for you
in the soul nor from an experience
what are your thoughts on creating a meaningful
story versus one that's commercial I think it all
depends on your goals if your goal is to create
something commercial go for it I think that
there's no shortage of opportunities to
create something commercial there's no
shortage of it because as you can see that's
what's being thrown at most of us all the time
it's something commercial that has mass appeal
and I think it's superficial I think it's easy
you can take the money and run it's what they call
it legal bank robbery it's if that's your thing
I think that for a lot of people who are not
for people who are driven by
quelling that voice inside
that won't really work I think you're always going
to have to be making something meaningful whether
it's meaningful to you or meaningful
to audiences in general because
that's how you that's how you you feed that thing
inside of you right that need to get that that
creativity out you're creating creating something
that means something to you in that moment if
you're constantly if you are a person who desires
to make meaningful material and you're constantly
having to stuff that down while you make something
commercial you're not living your best life
you're not living your best life and ultimately
that's all we want to do that's all we want to do
as artists is live our best life create stuff and
get it out there and then create something again
and get it out there and for for a great number
of people creating something commercial is great
you you go out there it takes you maybe a
couple weeks of work and it's off because
when it a lot of the times for especially for
the stuff now that's like your marvels and
anything that's disney related and it's high
concept those guys have a paint by number formula
you can stack all those movies one on top of the
other and they'll hit the same beats all the way
through and that's good that's awesome they know
what their audiences want and those writers have
an easy job they know by this moment this needs
to happen by this moment this needs to happen
if that feeds their soul or their bank account
I say power to them hopefully it does both
hopefully does both but if you desire to make
meaningful content you really have to get that
out even if it's if you're a writer it's just
writing the script just purging it getting it
out of your system and then you turn around and
you write something commercial but you have to
get out of your system you have to feed that
beast why is it so hard to make a great movie
that's a good one I think one it depends on your
definition of great I think that so many people
are caught up and everybody else said it was great
and I think that's where most movies go wrong
somebody will tell somebody oh your movie's like
this but with a little bit of that and they go
I didn't see that but okay and then they go
back and they start looking at that movie and
they want to polish it now and make it a little
bit more like that movie and it's that whole
it's that whole like looking at the guy next to
you thing and judging yourself by how far you've
gotten ahead of everybody else that you're that
is your peer or your your colleague or whatnot
trying to try to just get ahead of them and
judging yourself judging your success by how much
more success you've had than them and
that includes making a great movie
I consider a great movie to be one where I
watched that movie and I couldn't turn it off
I couldn't turn it off that's watching
it though I couldn't turn it off
one of one of my favorite movies
is 44 inch chest nobody's seen it
well I shouldn't say that let me not say nobody's
seen it most people in the u.s haven't seen it
but it's called 44 inch chest I love that movie
from beginning to end and then I went online
one day and I saw the reviews and I'm like I was
like what I don't get it this movie was incredible
couldn't take my eyes off the screen it was so
well written every element of filmmaking was done
to the nth degree I just didn't understand it
right so I don't know if certain people walked
away going I guess we didn't make a great movie I
felt they made a great movie I felt they made one
of the best movies ever I did and it's a small
little movie takes place in a flat I think it's
an incredible movie I think it's a great movie a
lot of other people didn't think so but maybe the
person who made the movie said that's exactly what
I wanted to make because that's how I would feel
when I sit down and I watch a film of mine
it's all about how much of what was in here
made it on the screen and if it made it on
the screen it went one day when I get to
at least 93 percent of whatever I wanted to being
on the screen I'm gonna say that's a great movie
that's a great movie that's a successful movie
I've made something successful because that's what
success means to me that's what a great movie made
by me means right and I'm hopeful that that person
who made 44-inch chess felt that way because maybe
people don't feel that that was a great movie
you said it was a foreign film
it's made in the uk it has ray
it's gonna bother me that I can't remember his
name but hum leota no no no no no not rayleigh
he was in he was in uh the the jack nicholson
movie when he played the gangster the irish
gangster with leonardo dicaprio and all those
guys I can't remember his name right off the
top of my head but you've seen him a million
times and when you see forty four hours oh fine
no it's like I want to say it's like roy ray like
I don't know why I want to call it like [__]
bird or something like that but I know that's not
what it is but it's as soon as you see him you're
going to say oh that guy but it's him it's so many
people so many names so many people that you're
going to recognize immediately right as soon as
it starts you're going to see four people you've
seen in every movie you've ever seen and you're
gonna say oh okay but they're all uk actors right
and the story is very simple there's a 44 inch
chest and there's a guy inside of there and
the main character the protagonist is trying
to decide should he kill him or not kill him
very simple premise he invites his friends
over his friends are gangsters just like
he's a gangster and they're trying to help
him work through his problem to decide if he
should kill this guy do who this guy is this
is the guy that's been sleeping with his wife
in the whole movie I'm not ruining it
that's the movie they're trying to decide
should he kill the guy or shouldn't he that's the
whole movie and I'm telling you it is a perfect
movie from start to finish does it take place
in one room it doesn't take place in one room
but definitely in one one flat okay one flat it
it's incred it's done to an incredible level of
filmmaking writing directing editing score
everything is incredible the acting is impeccable
the special effects are impactable yes
there are special effects even in this
this small film everything was done so
perfectly so the definition of great
is really kind of subjective in terms of
why is it so hard to make a great movie
I think if you have succeeded at accomplishing
what you wanted to accomplish and you you feel
successful in it it's a great movie in terms of
one that you've made now if you are talking about
just watching movies yeah there's a lot of
movies that will let you down and maybe maybe
maybe this person who thinks that they made
a great movie was just like a guy who I was
telling you about who stunted his growth because
all he's concerned about is how he measures up
against the other filmmakers that he knows in
his peer group and if he's thinking about that
and he's constantly throwing in stuff and falling
back on bad habits and never growing he may be
satisfied but he hasn't made a great movie I
think that you have to be beyond that one of the
one of the best quotes is is from
the art of war where it talks about
making yourself invincible right and invincible
doesn't mean that you can't that you win that
doesn't mean you win all that invincible means is
putting yourself beyond the possibility of defeat
and the only way to do that is by truly knowing
yourself you truly know yourself and not
spend your time so concerned with what everybody
else is doing it's one of the reasons why I took
down my personal profile on facebook I don't want
to know what everybody else is working on I just
want to focus I just want to focus and I want to
grow that's all I want to do is focus and grow
and so you have to be without that vanity you have
to be without that ego so that you you have the
ability to grow and when you are making something
your constantly growing and getting better
and you can understand what didn't work what
did work you can understand how could I have
better communicated that so that it ended up
on the screen the way that I wanted it to and
how close did I get to the vision that I had
in my head how close did I really truly get
and even with one to one where I consider it
to be my best film to date if you ask me how
close I got i'd say 75 if I'm being generous with
myself from being generous with myself I got 75
I'm trying to get in the 90s I'm trying to get in
the 90s and so that I can consider it a great film
so that I can consider it a successful
film I find that our greatest enemy besides
constant comparing yourselves to your peers
the enemy of great or the enemy of good is
sometimes trying to be great as opposed to
just trying to make the best movie
possible you're trying to be great
don't try to be great just try to be truthful and
honest to the story to your characters try that
be as honest and truthful as you can in
that moment that story like I said made
that truth may not resonate with everybody in
the sense of it's their truth but they have
to understand that you were being honest when
you were making this film one of the 48 laws of
power that I feel that people overlook is the
one that it says always know your effing with
in this industry it's so easy to just
cast someone aside and say this person is
nobody person doesn't matter this person isn't
someone that can help me get to the next wrong
because you're so caught up in yourself right
you always have to take time to and I'm gonna
back out of it to say it from another perspective
you always have to step outside of what you're
trying to accomplish and understand that your main
objective too is to be of use and to be helpful
because if you're of use and helpful
people like to have you around
if you're willing to share your knowledge and
your experience people love to have you around
so don't think about always what someone else
can do for you understand what you can do
to help them as well in all of that never
treat someone as if they're insignificant
or if they don't matter always know who you're
effing with because you never know that one
person could have been the key to an opportunity
that would have completely changed your life you
have no idea even if you are I preach so much
about taking your destiny in your own hands
but you don't have the ability to control
much of anything outside of yourself
these other people can open doors for you and
it may be that maybe you open the door for them
and you just walk through with them maybe you just
help this person go to the next level and then
they say what I remember that time this guy you
just never know so always know who you're effing
with which law is that that's good oh I don't know
which one it is but it's in the 48 laws of power
always know who you're having with I have to go
back to it yeah maybe maybe i'll re-listen yeah
that that book is I think it's a a more timely
version of art of war so I think sure I think
it's better written for for this period justin we
had this comment come in from one of our viewers
and it reads guys I'm so scared there are
a certain amount of movies I want to create
and I figured the best route to start would be
with screenwriting but I just wish I had a guide
or something for the journey it seems like
people really spend years doing so much work
and only have results after like a decade
I'm not sure if I want to be a screenwriter
but I do know that I have movies I want made
help what advice can you all give me so wow
pictures that he wants to get made but not quite
sure how to go about it and doesn't want to spend
decades doing something he doesn't love or she
don't doing stuff they don't love in order to make
that happen I would say pick a discipline and know
that that's your focus and just start making stuff
just start making stuff I think everybody gets
so caught up in all the reasons why they can't do
something they never think about why they can and
I don't know what that is about us as artists that
that makes that thought pop into your head but
whenever I do something my my wife will tell you
I tell you a thousand and one reasons why we'll
succeed and you'll have to tell me all the reasons
why we can't and i'll tell you every reason why
I can overcome that too that's really what it's
about get out there and make it happen just get
out there and make it happen if that screenwriting
isn't where you want to be see if you can get
somebody who is a screenwriter to do that part of
it and then you just get out there and you make it
I don't know what it is this person was trying to
to what discipline they were trying to work
in whether it was producing directing writing
acting I don't know but whatever it is know that
that's your main thing and the pieces that you
don't want to concern yourself with in terms of
learning how to do it and becoming very proficient
I would say peace peace work that peacemail that
out like get someone else who is just as eager
to create something as yourself and say let's
create this together you handle that part i'll
handle these parts and just do it that way and
just get to creating just start creating stuff
have you always had that belief in yourself where
you can think of all these reasons why you will
succeed no no I don't think I've always had that
I think that I've always been I think I've always
been by myself wanting people to include me in
something and I went through my life with that
until one day I no longer cared what everybody
else was thinking or doing or willing to accept me
and that's what was able to help me become more
and more successful because I realized the only
difference between like I'm the only
difference between possible and impossible
that's really it I am so if that is the truth then
I don't really need any of these other people I
don't need their approval I don't need their
guidance I don't I don't need anything I can
go over here and start making my own mistakes
when I speak to someone else I want to learn
from their mistakes that's what I want to learn
from whatever advice you have it came from your
mistakes I want to know about your mistakes if you
have something to share if you don't just don't
stand in my way because the train is moving this
direction if you stand there i'll run you over
because this is where I'm going so I don't really
need any of it I can I can I came to a realization
that when I made adam k adam k if you look at
it I had to make up credits because I didn't
want to look like I did everything but I did
everything I did it was me and my wife she handled
holding the boom pole she did makeup she
did special effects she handled catering and
I handled everything else and it was the two
of us making a movie and we made it for 1500
bucks and everybody thinks we spend a crapload
more than that but nope that's all we spent
and it was proof I don't need a bunch of people
to make that happen and neither does anyone else
sit down take a camera or camera phone
or something and start shooting something
was there a specific incident or something that
happened that made you realize I don't I don't
need the group that you're willing to share no I
think it I think more than anything it was it was
the constant disappointment because when you're
starting out and you don't have very much money
you you start to see who will work with you
for very little money right so their incentive
is only that very little money that's it it's
not the passion it's not growing with you it's
not any of that stuff they have no investment in
your journey or theirs whatsoever they want that
50 bucks or 100 bucks that you can pay them and
guess what happens if somebody else comes along
and says they'll give them 200 bucks they will be
off your set and you will be there by yourself and
that happened to me excuse me numerous times
numerous times where people would just bail I
was shooting something a short film and they
just bail and that's it or they don't show up
and you're like what what is this and so I went
into to adam k and I just I wanted to see can I
shoot this myself I shot another film called bleed
for me and I shot that one completely by myself
that one was me taking the boom pole and propping
it up in a corner so that it would capture audio
and then I would shoot with it with the camera
and I would be setting up the lights and I would
order food and bring it over I literally
shot bleed for me by myself and edited it
but it was because so many people that I brought
aboard flaked just flaked and flaked and flaked
and I just I began to realize I don't need any
of these people actually it's good to have them
around it lightens the load a bit but I don't
need them and so once I once I really realized
that my only reason for bringing someone on
board if I have the money to pay them well
you only your your the reason why you're on this
project is because you do something better than I
could myself and you truly do lighten the load but
if it's something that I realize at any point that
I'm just better off doing it myself I will i'll
just do it myself because it's better off that way
how does someone maximize their chances for
breaking in in Hollywood whatever breaking in is
in the shortest answer the same way
you can increase your odds of winning a
boxing match throw a whole lot of punches
now does that mean you win no it just gives you a
puncher's chance right so if you just keep taking
your shot taking your shot taking your shot
eventually something will land hopefully now
if you're looking at a more skillful way to get
there and to continue to work I say perfect your
craft and constantly take opportunities
to get more experience and to be helpful
to put yourself in a position to better utilize
those muscles and those strengths of yours and and
make those weaknesses no longer a weakness make
them an advantage start to do that so that you
become you become not only better at the craft but
you can navigate the system a little bit better
because that is more helpful but I think those
are the ways you you increase your odds as well
in a more calculated way and tell
people too I tell this to actors
I tell this to writers I tell it to anybody
keep creating your own content keep creating
because even though you no one's going to come
looking just odds nobody's going to come looking
at your web series and saying that needs
to be on nbc that's not really happening
but what it does it allows you to grow it allows
you to do what most people would do in a film
school which is you get to fail and fail and
fail and fail until you're no longer failing
right our greatest enemy is that we keep
waiting for someone as someone to give us
a shot and if you haven't had enough shots
you're just failing under their watchful eye
that's all you're doing so why not do that on
your own just shoot some stuff get more experience
work through your strengths understand what
your strengths are and what your weaknesses are
and begin to work through those things and make
those your advantages as well and just become
all around a great technician in your craft as
well as a great creative in your in your craft.